hello everybody hello hello a lot of stuff has been going on
i was trying to remember what the fuck happened on sunday
and monday um and why we haven't had our schedule today i
was just trying to like retrace my steps because i was like
so busy anyway if you guys see on my top left that oh the
dokey bear controller yes the dokey bear controller is back
in stock but it has been back in stock for like a couple
weeks now but i keep forgetting to talk about because of
everything else that's going on.
But the Doki Bird Controller is back now!
Let me see.
So if you guys want to grab, you guys missed out, you can
grab the Doki Bird Controller right now.
Grab your own, because I will be playing the Lego Batman
game with the Doki Bird Controller as well so we can match.
All right, grab your own Doki Bird Controller right now.
Using the controller right now as we speak.
All right, let's...
Let me pin...
Oh, whoa, I went to my own channel accidentally.
Pin that message.
Sorry, I had a lot of stuff I had to answer to just now.
That's why I had to loop.
Oh, my God.
Busy, busy cat.
Yes, I'm...
Do-Kitty is here right now for today's special stream.
I was trying to decide what to...
Oh, whoa, Do-Kitty is gone.
And Do-Kitty is back.
Sorry.
I was trying to decide...
like to uh what to stream today will there be a hangout
because you know i'm like uh i was like oh maybe we should
hang out and i realized oh the new batman game just came out
um and i heard about how fun uh i was like looking at twitch
and being like what are people streaming right now just to
see if i can yoke my yoke my now yoke give me that thing
yoke meow anyway sorry i was like yesterday last night i was
i fell asleep to a marvel rival stream and they were playing
uh black cat and i swear to y'all i heard was like y'all y
'all y'all i'm like oh my god someone please kill the cat
killing that's all i hear y'all y'all
Anyways, um, Jakarta, they use the super chat thingy-tey.
You won't be needing that.
Um, anyway, at a PTSD, uh, Chatbox is broken.
I think, like, YouTube has been playing around with their,
uh, with their, like, chat thing, through like coding shit
so like the chats always like the chats keep getting
breaking for some reason because of it um Jakarta leave the
super chat thank you thank you 20 years a Lego Batman Lego
Batman sets originally started in 2006 and the first game
being 2008 so many dragoons are very nostalgic for it so
we're super excited to see Doki play the first Lego game yes
I've never actually played a Lego crossover game before um
the one the only game Lego game I've ever played was a pizza
delivery one, like, from that you can get from Costco.
Um, you know, like, the, when Costco used to sell video
games, um, and, like, PC, this, you know, stuff.
Um, but, uh, yeah, that was, like, the, the first and only
Lego game I've ever played.
I've never played any of the other crossover.
Yeah, Lego Island, yes, yes, I used to play a lot of Lego
Island.
I had no idea what the fuck I was doing because when I was
that young, um, I didn't really understand English, even
though it was my first.
I don't know.
know maybe I just didn't like listening to things um I just
didn't I didn't understand instructions I wouldn't say I
didn't understand English I just didn't understand being
told what to do so I remember like the game was trying to
tell me to do stuff but I didn't really understand what it
was trying to tell me to do so I just clicked random things
around but I just remember fond memories of me clicking
random things I don't know what the fuck I was clicking um I
don't know what was going on but I was like I just remember
it was a pizza game that's I can remember there was in it um
i didn't understand being told what to do i was like what's
that it's like buttons go so um that was the only the first
and only lego game i've ever played uh but i heard a lot of
people were looking forward to the new batman lego game
coming out which i mean it did come out technically if you
pre-ordered the deluxe version which i did um and i was like
you know like I was looking at Twitch trying to be like,
what are people playing right now?
So everybody's either playing Forza Horizon, the new racing
game, or Lego Batman.
And I heard Lego Batman, the first Lego Batman, did really,
really well and holds like a special place in a lot of
people's hearts.
And then people were seeing the newer Lego, the Lego Batman
legacy is like an even bigger improvement to the original
Lego Batman game.
So I was like, you know what, fuck it.
Let's give it a shot, you know?
Let's see.
Let's try it out.
Like I never played Lego Batman before You know I could have
done armor court But I feel like you guys would want to know
when I'm playing armor court So that's why That's why I
didn't play it for today I was like you know let's try out I
feel like people would want to know when I'm playing Lego
Batman too Because it's just literally like one hour before
the stream Be like whoa Doki is gonna be streaming Lego
Batman There's always like a game be like Will Doki stream
today I'm like where's the schedule Doki Where is it how
would I dope your play today?
So yeah like the reason why there was no schedule right now
literally right now it's because um there i was trying there
was like a lot of stuff going on and i was trying to wait
for confirmation on things as well um so um um so basically
uh i think when was it i think on was it monday or sunday
that went mad i think it was sunday yeah on sunday i went uh
but i didn't what did i do on my oh um what did i even
fucking when did i what time up on I'm just like what the
fuck did I do on Monday I don't just like oh yeah I was like
what did I even do on Monday I don't remember what I did
last night on Monday I was like the first half of Monday I
legitimately don't even remember what I did on the first
half of Monday wait what did I do what did I eat okay okay I
remember okay yeah okay I remember Monday um I gotta block
that I walked dad Mondays.
I know Monday's always a blur.
I try to not remember Mondays So Monday I woke up.
I'm retracing my steps here And then I got pizza.
I went back home and then I slept for a couple of hours.
I took a nap And I got up.
Oh, and then I cleaned my apartment.
Okay.
Yeah, I remember now So on Sunday, Sunday is where I bought
my new bed.
So basically the last two days was a lot of stuff going on.
So on Sunday, I bought my first bed slash mattress slash
pillows slash bed sheet.
I just went all in.
I was just like, I'm here anyway.
So if you guys didn't know, this one never bought my own
like bed slash anything bed related before because my
parents used to do that for me.
And my current bed, By like tomorrow my new bed's coming in
but my current bed.
Yeah the full package It's like around eight plus years old
and like, you know, my parents bought it for me and
everything They bought the bed frame.
They bought the pillows the bed sheets like my pillows are
fucking disgusting Like they've been with me for I do wash
them, but you know like even when you wash them You're just
like I should really replace these pillows, you know like,
you know after when you take it out When you take it out of
the bed covers, like the pillow cases, you're like, oh, god.
Yeah, you're just like, holy fuck, okay.
And I've always told myself, like, I should replace, I
should replace my pillows.
I should replace, like, I should start replacing stuff
because it's been like eight plus years now.
And I haven't replaced them in, you know, cause like, you
married my parents would be the one to replace all these.
So I was like, it's time.
it's and I drool too by the way I also drool when I sleep so
um anyway anyway so I was like it's finally I've been
passing by this mattress store like at least once a week
whenever I do actually touch grass I was like I should
finally I should do it I should finally replace everything
um and also the reason why is because to replace everything,
I also need to clean my apartment because like there's no
space for the guys to come in, move my mattress out and also
my bed frame up because there's a lot of boxes.
There's a lot of boxes everywhere.
I will need to move some stuff in my room as well to clean
up some of the stuff in my room as well.
Um, so, you know, I finally took the step.
I was like, I, I, this is it.
I'm walking past this mattress store again.
It's finally I should finally replace my whole bedroom.
So, um, I walked there.
And then, you know, I don't know how to test beds or
mattresses or anything.
Also, one of the biggest reasons is while I was changing my
bed sheets, um, on Saturday.
And I was like, I looked at my mattress and I was like, it's
time.
I was just like, oh, weird.
Oh, man.
yeah I think it's time I sometimes you just know yeah I was
just like yeah I looked at my matches and I was just like oh
it's time it's it's finally time I can't I can't postpone it
anymore I'm on George thank you for chat thank you thank you
congrats Doki you're one step closer to so proud of you.
Doctor, thank you.
Thank you.
Hi everybody.
Hi Dr. Nick.
Um, anyway, so I went to the mattress store and I was just,
they're like, oh you should test, they're like, you should
test the foam mattress out.
You should test the bed springs and then the foam, and
they're like, how do you feel?
And I was just like, it's all right.
It's cool.
It's good.
It's all right.
And then they went to the other mattress, like how do you
feel about this mattress?
And I'm like, it's cool.
It's And then went to the third match.
How do you feel about this match?
It's cool, it's good, it's all right.
I don't know, everything feels like it's just, I don't know,
it all feels good.
It all feels cool, it's all right.
I'm so bad at thinking.
And it's just like they're all so cool.
They're all, they're all so cool, it's good.
It's all right.
It's a fed.
so because they're like oh this one's softer this was a
little hard okay I could tell when it was like super hard I
was just like that was not cool not all right that one when
they and then they gave me a super hard matches and I was
like that one was not cool not all right
so um there's that but then the other mattress they all felt
so similar i couldn't really tell like i couldn't really
tell like the difference between the other mattress the foam
one and the the bed spring one they're just like always like
they're just like oh for the foam like um it's more so like
if you're like sleeper and you have someone else in your bed
You get the foam mattress or something so then like the
person they can't feel it if the other person moves and i
was like Oh, so but i'm not a light sleeper and also like I
don't think I can feel dad like move on my Like I
legitimately I legit the only way for dad to wake me up is
is if is if like he gets off of out of bed and starts
barking at me so like be like feed me that's the only way um
that's the only way for like anyone can like such a heavy
sleeper um like like alarms can't even wake me up like i
have to have the phone be like 20 meters away so i had to
get up and um i have to get up and like turn my alarm off so
um so that's why i was like it was so hard because i was
just like all these i was just looking at that point i was
just looking at prices i was just looking at prices be like
more expensive equals better?
I don't know.
I'm so bad at it.
I'm so bad at looking at this.
So I was just like, I don't know.
They all look like they're all feds.
I can't tell.
Um, so, um, so I was like, more dollars equals more good?
Question mark?
Because I couldn't.
I, all the feds seemed great.
All the matches is like, I don't know how to pick.
Um, They're like, oh, and then, and then they're like, oh, I
know a bed for you.
And they took me to this mattress with a remote.
And then, and I was just like, why is there a remote for a
bed?
Like, what is this?
And he was like, oh, yes, you can adjust the shape of your
mattress.
And I was like, oh my God.
the future is now I was just like you can adjust your
mattress and he's like lie down and I'll show you and then
literally you can you can basically move the mattress it can
go like the top half can go up so you don't have to stack
your pillows at all you can it will just move up and then
it's like your old It's like a hospital bed, basically.
It's like your own personal hospital bed.
But like, you don't have to go to the hospital, but you
don't have to be like in debt for it.
Yeah, bed go up, bed go down, bed go up, bed go.
Oh my God, it can fold you like a fucking taco.
Yeah, the legs go up too.
Bro, okay, it was crazy.
He was folding me up like a taco.
And he's like, oh, and then like, apparently it has an
anti-snore feature.
So, uh, so, so basically I was like, what's the anti-snore
feature?
And so he pressed that, like, it's like, if you are, if
you're prone to snoring, you press this button on the remote
so that if the bed can detect the snores, I was like, it can
detect snores?
Oh my God, this is like an, it's like an AI bed.
Like, it's a smart mattress.
It's a smart mattress.
Basically, if it's here's you start snoring, the mattress
will, uh, will, the mattress will move up.
So, like, the top half will start folding up.
So, yeah, better circulation.
So you can breathe better.
It's listening.
It's like, Siri, it's always on.
My mattress is always listening to me.
And don't worry, it's just sell my data to the government.
But everything else, I'm a streamer already.
So everything else is already being sold to the government.
Yeah, it will raise your head to open your airways and to
listen
So so basically if I start snoring the It basically the bed
will start like will start moving up So it'll start raising
my head and then I then so like it will make yeah So it will
make sure I won't like I could breathe more I guess It's not
a subscription.
It's one time.
It's a one time purchase.
Don't worry.
It's not a one month like a tiered subscription.
Uh, it's not a tiered subscription at least.
Uh, night.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm really hoping you didn't buy a subscription bed that
makes it unburied asleep on when yourself expires.
Girl, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You should have brought dad.
I should have brought him.
I think he'd be the best these mattresses think of a super
chat thinking thank you it's not black mirror episode i
swear i swear guys it's not black mirror episode anyway
other than that um it also has a massage vibration feature
so like if you want so it would like your bed my mattress
can vibrate guys it can yeah like and then like in in one to
two years they're gonna try start introducing ads while i
sleep it's subliminal message.
So like the moment it detects that I've fallen asleep, it's
just going to start fucking putting ads for McDonald's and
like Honda Civic or something.
The matrix vibrates, guys.
I don't know what I'm going to do with it.
I just was like, oh my god, that's just a feature, you know.
I just, it's like additional feature.
And then it could sink in so like the meta can sink in like
a fucking pothole i don't fucking know what it's for though
i really don't know i know that if like machines do rise up
they can kill me instantly but i think that's a sacrifice
i'm worth that it's worth taking um i think that's a
sacrifice i'm willing to risk guys if the if the ai starts
rising up and i'm sleeping in that bed i may I might be the
first one to go.
I hope you get to play Gunball one of these days.
Leave a super chat, Korog.
Thank you.
Yeah, I might become a taco.
But oh my god, what a way to go.
So I also bought upgraded from a queen size to a king size.
Just so I could, like, I guess, like just so I can have roll
around more in the bed I don't know I just wanted a
king-size bed I was like I would I had the room for it I
might as well go like just full comfy um and I also have to
buy a new bed frame and everything for it too like a oh my
god it has drawers okay for the new bed frame um I was like
debating which one to get because I was trying to you mean
more space for dad that's true sometimes dad um takes up
like much like he would just be like i'm gonna sleep in the
middle now and i was like please move and he's like no and
then if i when i it's so okay he's i didn't take up most of
the space or he sleeps on top of my legs i was like there's
so much room why are you here and he's like but i want to be
right here like literally just on top of my legs i don't
care where i i don't care where you are gonna sleep but i
want to sleep right here or in the middle of my bed it's one
or the other um anyway i was debating on what to get for the
bed frame because like i don't i never bought a fucking bed
frame before but um because like it was i so but i decided
to pick one where um where it was like basically dad won't
be able to go under the bed anymore like he doesn't have his
little goddamn hidey hole anymore like that was fall under
the bed or like he would hide under the bed so I bought a
bed frame that just that just takes up the entire floor so
he can't hide under the bed anymore and oh but but I have
drawers though my bed frame has drawers so I could put bed
sheets in oh my god I feel I feel like such an adult I'm
like guys guys my bed frame has drawers guys oh my like the
most the most But it's like oh my god, guys, I have drawers
on my bed frame.
Oh my god I'm so excited
Yeah, there's it's so convenient and Like imagine the
storage space guys.
Oh my god But it's so relatable Now, I have, I can, I don't
have to put it under my bed and then having the bed down,
look under the bed and get the stuff out.
I can put my bed sheets in my bed frame drawer.
I'm all growing up now.
I have bed frame drawers now, guys.
Also, Jen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Joki, it was my birthday yesterday.
You think I could get some belated birthday wishes?
Of course, of course you can.
Happy birthday, happy belated birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Gen X.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Yay.
That's when you become a real adult.
Being, like, being so happy about more stories.
space so and anyway um so anyway I got a king-size bed um I
have king-size mattress a king-size bed frame now well
they're coming in tomorrow so I have the wait till tomorrow
um and then also I got new pillows because like I said I
changed the pillow covers on my pillows and I was just like
I think it's time just like the mattresses I was just like I
think it's time
and then i was like telling all my friends about it i was
like oh yeah i got some new pillows and they're like what's
wrong with your old pillows i think you could still use your
old pillows or just change the bed guys like no you don't
understand it's it's been years i've had these pillows i was
almost as long as these as the mattresses and then i took i
i like took a picture of the pillows without the pillow
covers because i brought the new pillows so i brought three
new pillows
um so um and like it didn't matter but and i bought like
three different pillows by the way three different pillow
pillow brands they were very expensive they were like 200 to
300 because like you know i want to like look into like
long-term wise i don't want like i don't want to like
replace any of these anytime soon like i said um like i said
like i had a lot of my stuff from my bedroom for a long time
already it was like eight plus years so uh when i buy these
things it was for like long-term comfort where I was
thinking about not replacing them for a while type deal so
it's not like so I don't have to replace them because like
like I said like I had these pillows for like eight plus
years now and same with the bed eight plus years and
apparently beds and mattresses are supposed to last you for
10 years um and that's what they were saying they were like
uh if you have a really good mattress a really good bed it
should last
why I wanted.
I was thinking like, if I get good pillows, good bed, I
won't have to replace it in a long time.
And there's a 10-year warranty.
I didn't even know that was a thing.
You get 10-year warranty on your mattress, I think.
Yeah, 10-year warranty on your mattress.
Papa Smurf.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Azumiku's birthday was Saturday.
Can they get a happy birthday?
Are you Azumiku, Papa Smurf?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Chicken, welcome to Mail Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Anyway, so for the pillows, for the I got one because I
didn't know what pillow I would like because I said they
gave me like so many different pillows to try and then I was
just like they're all so good like I don't know so one of
the pillows I got was the newfangled tech pillow technology
that I remember I saw on the internet one time it's the one
where it has like the hexagonal shape like like I don't know
if you guys saw it it's like these pla it's so crazy it's so
weird it's like those plastic hexagons and shit it's like i
was like oh my god like the new advanced pillow technology i
and it's like anyway i'm not using i i i did not using that
i got the pillows by the way i have the pillows just not the
mattress or the bed the hexagonal pillows i was like what
the fuck is this anyway i didn't i'm not i'm using the
backside um i'm trying to see i could find a picture of it
oh this it's like Latex like is it that I don't remember
it's like there it's like it's like one side is that is like
Like hexagons.
It's so fucking weird.
It's like plastic hexagons as opposed to like improve your
neck or some shit Um It's like something to do with like
improving like like making sure your neck is comfortable I
don't fucking know.
I just know it looked it looked so cool I was just like damn
the pillow technology.
It was like some plastic shit on top.
Anyway, anyway, I use the other side because the other side
is like cooling The cooling side and I like it when my
pillow is cold Um, and then the other one is just like those
cooling pillows where it's like a soft cooling pillow One is
harder one is softer.
So like I mix them up which one I want to hug Oh, so, but I,
but then, but like I bought those three and, um, and I
brought it home and they're nice.
They're nice pillows.
They're also not yellow.
Oh yeah, but anyway, I took a picture of the pillows, showed
it to my friend, and they're like, you should throw them
away.
They're like, why are you throwing them away?
It's such a waste.
At first they were like, don't throw them away.
Just keep it for it.
Like, just wash it.
And then, like, swap them out.
Like, whenever you have to wash your other pillows.
And I took a picture of the pillows.
Send it to my friend.
And they're like, you should throw them away.
You should.
They instantly changed their minds.
Tango, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I sleep on $100 food on the floor.
Like, I always have for $30.
plus years soft beds are for weenies thank you for the super
chat thank you thank i do watch those pillows i do watch
them it's just it's a it's i had these pillows for eight
plus years guys like it's like eventually something was
gonna happen to those pillows uh
um anyway um anyway so i got new pillows uh so and
Yesterday, I spent majority of the day, I spent majority of
the day just cleaning my apartment.
Like I said, I needed to clean my room.
And also I needed to clean the entrance way leading to my
room and moving some of the boxes around.
So, you know, they can come in and assemble my new bed, my
new mattress, and disassemble my bed frame and everything.
so that's what I spent a majority of yesterday doing um but
yeah I mean good good step you know uh I finally bought my
own bed my own mattress my own pillows um new bed sheets too
new bed sheets because my old bed sheets were for queen size
bed not for king size so and I don't think I've ever had a
king size bed before so it's gonna be nice I get to have
more room to roll around in and also never get out of bed
for i know dad's gonna be really fucking happy that's for
sure he won't have his i would be really happy too because
he wouldn't have his little hidey hole space as well so yeah
that's what i've been doing um the last two days um what
else what else zipongo yes i almost forgot to talk about
zipongo so matara and i were having zipongo it was such a
great experience meeting everybody seeing everybody outside
it was like those like outside music events and everything
and it wasn't even like super crowded too uh right thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you it's god it's too
late i already dispose of it it's already in the compactor
it got compacted it i'm sorry right it's too late it's god
now you gotta dig through the trash for it um but anyway i
had a really great time like um i was really surprised i was
really worried there won't there won't be a lot of like
people there for us only because it was a you know um it was
notified like within a week um like a week's notice and and
also like um you know it was a huge it was a big event it
was a big music event where there's like a lot of big you
know it's really funny too because like while this was you
know during all that time that was happening there was a
whole discourse about like um how it was so difficult to see
japanese artists or japanese like uh people like japanese
artists um out of japan because of how hard it is to even
get tickets in japan and stuff and everything like i saw a
lot of people talking about it on twitter too i don't know
if you guys saw the twitter like the twitter feed about the
whole like discourse about it how like um a lot of japanese
artists tend to not go on tours overseas uh because it's
just a huge events investment because like even when they
want to tour in japan it's really difficult to tour in japan
it's it's like in their own country as well um so they're
saying like oh just please continue supporting the people
were like we want to go we want to go and support like the
overseas fans were like we want to go support you guys but
it's like we can't even get tickets in japan so um it was
such a uh i was like what what like timing too because there
was zippungu there was zippung pungu right now but well not
right now but during in saturday uh Pasadena and it was a
huge opportunity to see all these like uh big uh Japanese
singers big Japanese artists uh when um in America um and
they're all like just there doing their sets too and
everything and it was such a cool opportunity there was a
like like I said it wasn't even like super duper crowded or
anything like it was you know like super duper congested
like everybody was just like out there having fun walking
around and artists and like in between sets like because our
meeting greets was during in between the sets and stuff so
whenever a set was over people would be like walking out to
the rest of the area and you know they come over to the
Sipongu to like our meeting greets or and stuff and it was
so cool because like I didn't realize like we had to cut the
line we had to like turn people away for a meeting greet
because it was supposed to be only one meeting greet than
one that Matara and I were doing.
We were only going to do one meet and greet.
And because the organizers were telling us like, oh, are you
okay with doing another meet and greet later tonight?
Because like so many people, we had to turn so many people
away.
And a lot of people want to meet you.
And then, you know, Matara and I were like, no, fuck it.
Let's keep doing more.
Like, you know, such a huge opportunity, especially if guys
didn't know, the organizers who did Zipungu actually also
organized Coachella.
So I was just like, oh my, like, you know, I was just like,
you know what, like, you know what, like, what if you see
Doki Brit at Coachella next time, you know, so I was just
like, you know what, um, you know what, you know, um, I
know, I, you know, I felt really bad at, like, that some of
you guys got turned away, like, I didn't even think that I
personally was just like, oh, I hope like, we have some
people that are, we're gonna show up, I was really nervous
that we didn't have a lot of people show up, up and
everything and um and he's like i'm not going to go chela
anyway so i was just thinking like oh i was really worried
too going in um and being like oh i hope there's people that
will show up for the meeting because it was super last
minute and um i hope people are gonna be there and to say hi
to us and there were so many of you guys like so many
dragoons and so many momos there and I had a great time
talking guys so yeah I was like yeah fuck it let's do
another session and then for the other session Matara and I
actually went overtime too like we I think we went like 20
to 30 minutes uh overtime um for our uh for a meeting degree
for the second session and you know it's really great
meeting all of you guys I had a great time talking to all
you uh great time talking to Matara as well.
Oh, so I get to listen to free music while, you know, when I
was like meeting and like other set was performing, I was
just like, yay.
I get to listen to free music while I hang out.
I get to listen to their set while I'm there.
It was pretty cool because we're on
Yay!
Free attendance, the perks.
But it was really cool.
Let me see if I could grab a photo.
I know they sent some photos to me.
But like I said, it was basically like a giant billboard
truck.
And you guys could like see me and everything.
And it was really fun.
Let me see.
I'm going to grab.
I have a photo here.
But what the fuck?
Oh, okay.
I was going to say it.
Like, I was looking through, like, my images, and I was
like, what is this image I have that's on, that's, like,
that downloaded?
What is this?
All right, here's, like, what it looks like.
Dipongo!
I think it was really cool, though.
Like, they were able to get, like, yeah, so we were on this
giant billboard truck, and we were just there to hang out.
And so, like, I could hear everybody.
I could hear the free music.
Yay!
And everybody was just there.
chilling, hanging out, touching grass, and everything.
It was cool.
Like, I've never done, like, an outside... Have I done an
outside event before?
I don't remember.
I don't remember if I've done, like, an outside event, like,
a meet and greet before, but it was such a cool, such a cool
experience.
I really enjoyed it.
Um, um, yeah, I would love to do it again.
It was very, very, very fun.
Uh, but that, that was Zipango, but like I said, it was
crazy.
Like, the people they got there um who was it for those who
they had auto uh and like uh especially uh auto as well
because like her usually her concert like her concerts sell
out so fast too like uh like it's very hard to get tickets
to her concert so they had auto at 10 feet they had yuki
chiba mad of a mission hana chamiya atorashi gaka teddy lord
yeah it was just like like they had everybody yeah so um
great experience very fun experience um what else i want to
talk about uh i know i wrote some stuff down what else did i
want to talk about oh yeah you guys were like in chat early
oh um in chat earlier okay so if you guys didn't know i
usually don't read my business emails normally i don't um i
have my management that looks through all of them for me and
then and then um and then like he'll tell me if like stuff i
want to say yes or no to uh oh yeah anyway regardless it was
such and it was really cool meeting all the drag wounds
there uh too so thank you to all the drag wounds who stopped
by and said hi to us i really appreciate I was like I said I
was really worried in the beginning being like oh I hope I
hope we I hope people come meet us so I hope we're not just
standing there waiting but but it was like a full like you
know like we it was like a full lineup and everything like I
said we had to turn people away and then do like an extra an
extra session and went overtime and everything so thank you
guys again I really appreciate it it was really nice to say
hi up to all of you guys um
doing that i always love meeting dragons in the wild
especially guys the best part we were touching grass too it
was meeting dragons and we were touching grass um oh yeah
yes um okay i wrote this down so if you guys were not
looking at offline chat um um recently my manager told me
and was like hey so for those who don't know my manager
reads all the emails guys when you're sending an email to
the business email you're not sending an email to me you're
sending an email to my manager
let me reiterate it is not to me it is to my manager that's
where that's why it's a business email
So basically what happened was my manager was like, so you
have a new, uh, what's the word?
There's a new person emailing us lately.
Um, by the way, this person has sent us like around 300 plus
emails.
Apart from what my manager said, like it's 300 plus emails.
So anyway, so basically, and he was telling me about it.
and he was like he was like in the last I think like three
days in the last three days and then he was telling me so
this is why I was like moved okay so this is what caught me
super off guard not the 300 plus emails but bro was just
texting okay so it was basically my manager was like There's
this guy who
There's this guy that is convinced that his recommendations
are basically like Things YouTube recommendations is like
what it is basically me communicating with him so
So what he sees in his YouTube recommended is basically what
he thinks I'm also watching or like sending it to him being
like this is what I'm reply like the like he has like the
Doki algorithm or something like he thinks like he's
convinced that his recommendations were like the Doki
algorithm where we're like whatever I'm watching.
here whatever i want him to know is like basically what he's
getting from his algorithm you must like you yeah you must
it came to me in a dream it came to me in my for you page
i'll thank you for the super chat thank you thank you and so
and basically i was like oh my god i got
saw like someone wrote like um i was just like i don't i
don't know i don't even know how to process that is just
like the dokey algorithm like i thought when we had such a
stop super wide thank you thank you um and then like and and
then he sent me my manager sent me a screenshot and he was
like yeah, he thinks you're like asking him about learning
to cook because he kept getting recipes on his YouTube
algorithm at one point and he was like, are you trying to
and then he's like, are you trying to tell me to learn how
to cook because of all I'm getting is recipes and I'm like
what?
Cookie algorithm I'll have you guys know you know what the
last two days I was watching the last two days that's not
how it works so the last two days anyway the last two days
I've been watching I've actually been watching some comic
book retellings so I've been super obsessed with like
American American comics and I was not looking at recipes
that for sure i i was not looking at cooking recipes uh
don't you stop saying his subliminal messages hey guys i'll
recommend you guys i've been like super obsessed with uh
comic book retellings not like for like western comic book
retellings um and uh and uh i've been uh obsessed with I've
been obsessed with, like, what's his name?
I wrote it down.
And then it was like, Daniel, oh my God, what was his name?
Dan, the guy who wrote the plastics comics, but I love his
work.
It's like horror shit.
I've been reading a lot of Western horror comics lately.
I don't know why.
It's just my newest, my newest thing.
If you're, like, very squeamish about gore, about gore and
stuff.
And I won't recommend checking it out.
But I'm reading Doug Wagner.
of doug wagner comics um i think he did like what else did
he did he did plastics and uh oh my god he doesn't even have
his own wiki i am i supposed to know what he wrote there was
like several other ones there was one about um like a fat
fashion school but i'm trying to remember the comic title
okay it was fashion school serial killer uh plastic and i
think the latest one i read was uh i think i i read a little
bit of vinyl but i haven't finished oh yeah ice cream man i
read ice cream man as well i was reading i read ice cream
man um fashion school serial killer plastic i recently
started reading i hate fairyland um it's pretty shit okay at
first i hate fairyland was really good for those who've
never read it before i only recommend the first arc of it
When she becomes an adult and comes back to Fairyland.
So basically, I Hate Fairyland is a story about a little kid
who gets trapped in this mystical, magical world called
Fairyland.
And she gets trapped there for 40 plus years.
And it's like, yeah, it's this little green-haired girl.
And then her whole story is that she's trying to find her
way out of Fairyland.
Because you're supposed to go on a quest to find a key.
And then you can go home, but she's really fucking bad at
quests and very bad at directions just like me And then so
she's been trapped in this world for 40 years and like her
whole the whole story is just about her trying to get out of
fairyland And but then like then they and then she finally
Got out of fairyland and then the author decided to make a
sequel to that and it's really bad I I was just just
stopping at the part where she gets out of fairyland because
I'll spoil it a bit because it is really bad and I don't
want you guys to read the sequel.
So, so basically she got back to Fairyland as an adult
because like her whole like because like she realized being
an adult fucking sucks because she has no real life
experiences because she never got a job or anything because
she was a fucking child trapped in Fairyland.
So being adult was really bad.
So she's like, you know what?
Being back in Fairyland was pretty all right.
got back to fairyland and then they killed her off and then
then it suddenly followed it suddenly followed back to an
alternate universe of her that killed the adult fairyland
version of her and then it follows her but then she is now
stuck forever in fairyland like the alternate universe
little girl version of her killed the adult version of her
and then she was now stuck in fairyland because she doesn't
belong in this part of fairyland So, and then now it follows
her, like the back to the beginning.
So it's like, it's like nothing, none of it matters.
So in the end, like, none of it ever mattered.
So that's why, like, I would say read the beginning, but not
the sequel to it.
The sequel of it is not that great.
I think the guy, the author literally ran out of ideas,
being like, what the fuck do I do?
What do I do with this story?
I don't know anymore.
I'm pretty sure So But yeah That's why Oh Someone asked You
should read What was it Someone said There was a comic
series The one with a bear I did read it I finished I read
the sequel I didn't like the ending To the sequel The one
with the bear murderer The bear murderer comic I recommended
that before Beneath the tree Where nobody sees Really It's
very gory Like I said All these comics I'm recommending
right now Or like pretty gory and pretty squeamish i think
that's like majority of american horror comics in general um
a majority of american comics are usually just really gory
like i will admit they're like they're pretty gory and like
violent and stuff but they're like some of the stories are i
would say the stories are really interesting um uh the
storytelling is really interesting just you know it's just
very gory and blood everywhere um and but beneath the tree
where nobody sees it's a really good story it's very gory
too it's just it's like these like cute little animal like
um animal crossing type animals and uh um and uh and it's
very good story a very good storytelling character building
um the first version was really good beneath the tree where
nobody sees but they made a sequel to it uh and you made a
sequel to it and it starts off really strong and but then
the ending was it was ass the ending was so bad i was not a
fan of the ending um that's all i'll say i won't spoil that
one because i do really like the series for it everything
was so good until the last issue of the sequel um the last
issue of the sequel was just it like because it's like you
know it's like the boys right now today by the way the five
season today and it's like everyone's like how the fuck are
they gonna tie everything up together in the last episode
type deal that was what happened to the sequel of uh to the
sequel to beneath the tree where nobody sees there people
were like how are they gonna how are they gonna tie
everything up in the last issue and that's basically it the
every all the sequel to it was really really good right
until the last issue the last issue was where everything was
just i just didn't it didn't It didn't end the way that you
wanted it to end because it didn't really tie everything
together type deal.
It was just, it felt very anticlimactic to everything that
built up to it.
It just, the conclusion was just very rushed in general.
So that's how I feel about the sequel to Beneath the Trees
Where Nobody Sees.
I don't remember the, let me, what is the name for it?
Let me, I know there's a name to the sequel.
sees a sequel.
What was it called?
Right of Spring.
Yeah, but like, that's what the sequel is called.
There's another comic I've been reading.
It's about cats.
Cat's comic Shelter.
Where was it?
Is this called Shelter?
Horror.
It was about rabies.
I don't remember what it's called.
Pharaoh.
I've been reading Pharaoh lately too.
For those who don't know, But Farrell, I would...
Farrell is, like, on and off for me.
Like, there's some parts that's really, really good.
And then some that's, like, pretty men.
Um...
But...
It's basically a horror comic regarding cats.
And the whole idea...
It's, like, a zombie comic book.
So, Farrell is, like, a zombie comic series.
But, like, instead of zombies, it's, like, they're, like,
rabies.
So, like, the animal...
version of a zombie apocalypse is rabies so so there's a
rabies pandemic right now hitting like the specific town or
area and all the cats are like trying to figure out what the
fuck is going on so it's a very it's a very interesting
concept I've been reading that one on and off and I
sometimes the storytelling gets really fucking it's like
pretty bad but then sometimes it's like really really good
like there's some crazy shit the food is babies there's like
a scene in there where they encountered like this cat colony
from a pet store um so like uh basically it's really funny
i'll spoil a little bit so the cats these cats like uh pet
cats are like trying to find a shelter like a zombie
apocalypse they're trying to find like a sanctuary you know
a paradise sanctuary and then they they found a pet smart
like found a pet smart and then there's a you know but it's
already occupied by a lot of like the pet smart cats there
who don't know what's going on in the outside world because
right before all the humans left at the pet smart um they
like dumped a lot of food on the ground and then like and
then was like don't worry you guys will be fine we'll come
back for you and obviously like several days have passed
like weeks have passed and they haven't come back and then
the pet smart cats are like open cat and they're like we
don't we what do we do we can't open cats and we can't eat
dry food all the time we want we need protein we need wet
food because cats are like we don't have thumbs we don't
know how to open cans so so the leader of the pet smart cats
were like we have to eat the babies so you know they're like
we have to eat the baby so they mix the dry food with the
baby meat so they could get their that's their food because
they're like they're like just like when the when the
outside like when the pet cats not the pet smart cats like
the outside cats like the outside cats that were looking for
sanctuary like encountered the pet smart cats they're like
um they're like they went in and they found out that they
were they were eating baby cats they're eating babies they
were like are you crazy like you have food you have dry food
like then they're like and then they're like you're crazy we
can't survive on dry food alone we need protein we need meat
Because you're like, how dare you insist that we eat dry
food?
Like,
we need the luxury.
Like, I'm not crazy.
You are crazy.
The forbidden protein.
So there's like, there's that specific arc in there.
Like, yeah.
How fucking dare you suggest that?
So I don't know if I want to say I recommend Pharaoh.
In concept, I just found the concept super interesting.
Because it's like zombie apocalypse.
Like, oh, what if like, you know, what it's like for a
zombie apocalypse for like animals.
Yeah.
So it's just like the whole concept I thought was super
interesting in general.
Because, but it's not like actually like zombies.
so like they're like oh no he's infected and then he's just
like a cat with rabies jacquard i think it was super chat
thank you weirdly enough to tie back into batman dc there
was a dc comics battle royale tournament of crossover
characters which somehow had both samantha strong and home
ladder in it with other odd choices jacquard i think it was
super chat thank you thank you yeah it's like literally just
walking dead with um with cats uh
so um so yeah like i've been like honestly been like really
into like a lot of western comics lately and just been like
watch reading some of them and watching like retellings of
some of the some series and thinking about like like some
series recommendation which i did get into some of them like
i said i got into fairyland i hate fairyland um pharaoh uh
Doug Walker comics and where was the other one that people
were talking about?
Oh, Ice Cream Man too.
I read a little bit.
I read it.
I didn't finish Ice Cream Man.
I only read like a couple of issues for Ice Cream Man and I
heard a movie a movie was coming out about it.
What else?
What else I want guys to talk Oh yeah, I didn't make my
schedule.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I know I was supposed to play the game guys but I didn't
make my schedule real quick.
I'm so sorry.
I got too distracted But I am looking forward to trying out
I'm looking forward to trying out The new Lego Batman game
Like I said I never played an actual Lego game before Other
than the Pizza Time one So I'm looking forward to it I heard
there's a lot of references There's a lot of inside jokes To
a lot of other Batman games And movies and videos And stuff
over the years So, I'm really looking forward to seeing if I
recognize any of the references and stuff.
I think, I don't know.
I don't know if it's a good start as a good way to start off
my Lego adventure.
But, people are seeing it's really, really fun.
So, I'm looking forward to it.
I'm definitely tomorrow.
We're going to do, let's see.
Tomorrow we're going to do Armor Core.
But it has to be after all the bed stuff is done.
done, because the people are coming over tomorrow to, um,
people are coming, the people are coming over tomorrow to
piece my bed together and, uh, build my bed frame and throw
away my old mattress and putting my new mattress in.
And then Thursday, I don't know.
I'm trying to see Thursday.
There's my calendar app.
Um, Thursday, I don't know what to do.
I think Thursday I sort of want to play Heroes of Might and
Magic.
I think that's what I want to do at 1230.
I think Thursday, my EU stream will be Heroes of Might and
Magic.
The three.
Heroes of Might and Magic three.
That's the game I've always wanted to stream for a while.
I figured it's time.
Because I grew up playing Heroes of Might and Magic 3 a lot
growing up because it was my dad's hand me down.
And I've always enjoyed playing it.
I always so cheated a lot on that game because every time
like I started losing, I was like, it's angel time.
So I don't think I've ever played that game legit.
I either I do unlimited money or I do angel time.
So I've never actually beaten the game legit or like
actually, I never played a full map of it, like a full
state.
Like I think like I never played like, I never finished the
campaign legit.
tried to i was like angel time or unlimited money or fog of
war
i was like i need to see what everyone else is doing i was a
kid i could cheat back then that's right 10 angels 10 stacks
of angels and 10 units each and then every time it's like
insta kill insta kill uh friday will do arm oh saturday also
another reason why the schedule was out late it's because i
was waiting for dubi to reply but on saturday at 5 p.m we're
gonna have a uh dnd collab with marvel rivals um we're gonna
play marvel rival see it on saturday uh i told her i would
play tank so tank doki is resurrected from the again she is
she's back again for saturday and saturday only um so we'll
be playing tank with duvy on saturday uh at 5 p.m pst um so
that'll be and that's the schedule all right we'll confirm
the schedule i'll do this after stream i'll finish the
graphic after stream i think it'll be fine it's been an hour
so i feel like we should just start the game And Toki lives.
Heroes never die.
Um.
Alright, let's see.
Bapapapap.
Alright, I was trying to find the tab.
Let me set this up real quick.
That's gonna be on Saturday.
Uh, how many times tank doki is brought back here clearly
sooner for the roll?
No, no, I'm not.
How dare you imply that?
Gus, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
After, after Saturday, you'll never see her again.
For real this time.
Never ever.
She's gone.
She'll never come back.
All right, I got my controller too.
Because I know in the Lego games, you have to play with a
controller.
controller all right sound guy let me know whenever
everything's okay that's
what sooner ever say alan thank you the super chat thank you
thank you i'm no sooner i'm real i'm realistic my word is
law she'll never come back
ever she dies with me
see uh lego batman oh is uk united kingdom oh no they're
gonna add a u in my color all right uh uh too high i don't
think we need to be epic like i don't think i need to see
more pixels for the blocks i'm reborn again a tank dokey
will come back and avengers do no she's got she's dead you
gotta move on she'll be dead on saturday after saturday
select your age what happens if i select below seven will it
like well below nine will it like Wouldn't, like, child
protect me?
Is there, like, child sensors?
Or do child protection or something?
I get kid locked.
Oh, don't worry.
I think, like, it's just a menu where I'm lagging.
I'm pretty sure.
Probably.
The game only just censor everything.
Game will start playing.
It'll turn into mixtape.
It'll start playing itself.
Alright, we'll just go in the middle.
What's the middle between 9?
Guys, what's the middle between 9 and 27?
That is.
Quick maps.
What's the...
Oh, it had 17.
I have forever.
What if they censor alcohol?
I'm pretty sure there's no alcohol.
Oh, whoa.
Dad's angie.
Oh, yeah, it's feeding time.
Alright, quick, help me decide between the middle of 9 and
27.
I need to feed him.
It's 18?
Wait.
Okay, legally in America, to drink is 21.
so like unless so maybe we'll get alcohol so we'll do 21 oh
yeah by the way I forgot new announcement we have some new
volunteer mods so that will be moderating I know like I
forgot to tell my other mod my other staff so quiet silent
are the more the are silent the silent mods are the paid
positions they also handle some of the other behind the
scenes work not just moderating um the loud mods the ones
that start with loud they're the sound guys so they're the
loud mods so they help with sound balancing we have quiet
mods now but i think we should rename them dragoon so i
messaged the other the the side mods about it uh so we
talked about that's true that's true um new idea instead of
be Dragoon instead.
So their name, it starts with Dragoon instead of...
So the Dragoon mods slash quiet mods are the volunteer mods.
They're not the volunteer positions, so they're not paid at
all.
They're not paid positions.
And they're just there to moderate the channel.
So they're, yeah, the certified Dragoon.
I'm really optimistic that I'll see Tank Doki again for
something like Gunner Heat PC Neppers.
Thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So it's going to be like...
Silent, loud, and goons.
Or goon.
Actually, should we do goon instead?
Let's do goon.
The goons.
The volunteers will have goons in their name.
Instead of dragoon.
Alright, we'll do 21.
So we are legally allowed to drink in America.
Alright.
Skip.
I don't need a Warner Bros.
account.
Meow.
yoink i'm gonna need i'm gonna need that
the goon squad that's right it's coming back they're back
all right whoa
party music pack oh batman beyond Arkham trilogy dark night
oh shit wait which one do i want oh i'm lagging a little bit
let me adjust the video.
Subtitles enable, because I can't read.
I'll definitely not be able to read here.
I need a background audio.
What the fuck is the...
Oh, is it video?
Okay, it's video.
Uh, we'll do it.
144.
Hi, streaming.
Is there motion blur?
Lego mesh quality?
all right guys help me this decide i feel like we don't need
reflection
i'll do 50 i'm not a huge oh wait there is motion blur i'm
not a huge fan of motion the camera shake uh view distance
up i feel like view distance all high everything's really
high but i'm still lagging though oh my god this game is
this game is intense How am I lagging in bad Lego bat each
block is 100,000 triangles or some shit
Each block contains a hundred thousand triangles.
It's like the it's like the fucking fruits
Oh Unreal Engine 5 Wait epic okay 5 Wait,
why the fuck?
Yeah, hi.
Put everything high.
Alright, guys.
What do I turn down?
Motion blur is the devil's eyesight.
Mark, thank you.
Super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Guys, what do I turn off?
Because I'm lagging a little.
Maybe lower shadows?
Okay.
Reflections, shadows.
What else?
Has it applied yet?
That's a good question.
I think it has.
I think the moment you change it, it's applied.
Yeah, the moment you change it, it's already applied.
Is there V-Sync?
There is.
I'll turn V-Sync off.
Uh...
What else?
Ambient Occulation?
Where's that?
Oh, there you go.
Put that on low.
Maybe when we go in game, it'll be different, guys.
Maybe, I might be coping, but maybe in-game it'll be
different.
I could be coping, though.
Bloom?
All right, we'll get Bloom off.
All right.
May halves.
I could be coping, but let's see.
Let's create a new save.
Classic Cape Crusader mode offers a balanced focus on combat
and stories.
More enemies.
Advanced enemy type will appear more frequently.
The Dark offer harder combats for heroes seeking a
challenge.
Okay, um, should we do Classic?
Or Crate Crusader?
We're not doing Dark Knight.
I've never played a Lego game before.
Guys, I've never played a Lego game.
Toki, this is a kid.
It's gay.
I'm a baby.
I'm literally a baby right now.
All right, we'll do Cape Crusaders.
Tokyo It's Batman.
Come on, Bruce.
We'll be late for the movie.
Are you sure we can make it in time, Alfred?
Oh my god.
We get to see his kids get his dad's parents get shot.
I wonder if you're at nine years old do their parents just
like i mean what if they just like their parents disappeared
that's crazy they can talk great ghost i have to watch it in
my great ghost outfit yay crime alley what are we looking
for i need my cape my goggles and my hat i think i left them
in the garden somewhere all right oh yeah see i told you
guys i wasn't coping end game oh this is beautiful what the
fuck oh my god love oh okay one of the youtube videos i
watched like it's like from this uh lego master builder lego
man um that works at the lego experience store and he does
like crazy builds with lego i i it's so cool like seeing
this stuff this is why okay i personally never like growing
up i've only had one lego set because i i'm this is why i
also don't play minecraft because i'm not creative when i'm
building stuff yeah alex alex The master builder, Alec.
I love his videos.
It's so fun to watch.
He's so funny and so creative.
But, like, I just... I just... I'm just not creative.
I'm not as creative as these people when it comes to blocks.
I just don't know what to build.
All I do is just follow instructions.
Yeah, big gorilla.
Like, every time I see him build, I'm like, how does he do
it?
Allow me, sirs.
They crumble into blocks of that pig scene.
pop into pork chops probably rise thank you the super chat
thing thank you thank you look at anything useful nearby
it's so beautiful this is such a beautiful game oh my i'm
detecting i think i see my costume
i'm literally the chris pratt yes of lego movie caves are so
cool alfred do you know where my hat is i last saw it around
here master bruce now where on earth could it be yeah but
like the only lego set i've ever had growing up here in the
summer house somewhere was the uh oh my god an idea what if
there's two beds stacked on top of each other i'm so
creative but yeah the only the only lego set i've ever had
growing up is the one where it comes with like this like
little box it's like those like green box thing and then
like it has like green plate and then the two sides are
these like red container things with blocks in them and
stuff the double decker couch oh my god what if what if we
put two couches together and call it a double decker couch
oh my someone quick pat on it before they steal the idea
it's you so you can have two your friends and sit on couches
together.
I guess I should start tidying up after myself more.
Okay, I gotta open this.
So you and your friends can hang out and save space.
I found the goggles.
Yay!
I got the goggles.
Now I just need to find the hat.
I bring up the voices or the voice ladders are maxed out,
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, sound guy or loud breakbeat.
Oh, yeah, he changed the...
You already changed his name.
Loud break break.
Oh, I'm so cool.
Hey, why is it loud?
Loud BB breakbeat, the double Bs.
I think you might have spelled loud or you might have...
There might be a title in your name, sound guy.
this is fun wait i want to grab the coins you want to see
this movie or would you rather go for a swim all right to be
fair why am i going i bet you my own home theater my mansion
home theater is better than the regular theater because the
other one was taken no need to worry i'm rather good at
finding things all right where is it oh it's over here i see
it oh my god they're butterflies Fly Legos!
Oh, that's so cool!
The extra B adds a test.
Yeah, adds character.
It's like, adds another decibel.
Oh my gosh, did you guys know?
Okay, sorry.
I just reminded.
Not because I'm playing a Lego game, but I was just thinking
about something else.
But Tracers did it.
Apparently, studies have shown.
The Goon studies have shown.
shown have shown wait i could break the environment no i
can't um but the goon studies have shown oh my god i can but
tracer tracer has has dethroned chun lee in um in ass so so
tracer now has the biggest ass in fortnite in all of
fortnite the goon studies shown.
So Tracer is now the queen of ass.
Oh, I'm building.
I'm building.
Oh my god, I'm a master builder.
What?
Not scientifically possible.
The only study that matters.
Wait, I'll show you guys.
it I saved it all right let's see where is it yeah in
fortnight she's won don't worry I bookmarked it too I was
like I have to show look let me save this there's an
important update.
Life update.
Okay, where's my picture file?
Look at that.
There's more volume to it.
See?
Right here.
This is Chun-Li and this is Tracer.
She did it, guys.
I wonder if that was in the contract.
It is impossible.
Look at that.
Thank you, science.
Thank you to the researchers for giving us an important
update.
The update that we needed.
The man of Polly.
God count.
Check the Polygon!
Cat God cannot stand for this.
Alright, bring up the game or I'll bring everything that's
not dialogue related.
Okay, we'll do that.
Oh, even Master?
Sound guy or just like music and sound effects?
I'll just do that first and then
thank you to the hard working scientists for conducting this
research.
Finally.
A real size I can get behind on.
Yeah, academics doing God's work.
Giving us the updates that we care about.
That we gamers actually care about.
Alright, smash.
Found the hat!
Found it!
Out of the darkness comes.
The gray ghost!
That's me!
oh no we've got time but we need to be quick
someone quick we gotta give them a noble prize i gotta keep
collecting i might be a millionaire but how do you think i
stayed a millionaire there's a great ghost movie back when i
was a kid right whoa hey this dad's a hag a classic maybe
you'll appreciate it when you're a little older caution
what's so oh hey what's so dangerous all right oh it's mud
okay but then there's also more money here
oh sorry billionaires that's how they say billionaires
gotta keep on collecting
oh hey oh i want to be on a swing push me oh never mind i'm
too old for that wee
yeah keep on collecting hey dad i can't wait for you to live
very very long and old and see me grow up dad it's gonna be
great i can't wait for you to live just as long as just as
long as me isn't it great dad you're gonna grow up and see
me it's graduate college it's gonna be great I'm not scared
you're with me all right sound is good here that's good very
very subtle foreshadowing all right yeah we're gonna be the
best family ever and then everybody always remembers how bad
man has his parents grab it and let's get going the movie
starts soon surely nothing's bad's gonna happen to us in
crime alley where no crime happens Yay!
Did you know it's canon that the Teen Titans killed his
parents?
Alright.
Grab it.
Yes.
There you are.
Yeah, the Teen Titans killed his parents.
It's a canon event.
You're just jealous that Teen Titans had a hundred episodes
and that what other shows had in many episodes as teen
titans go you're just jealous um it won an award at the kids
choice award let's avoid these crowds and cut down crime
alley let's let's cut down crime alley is that a good idea
thomas i think it's called crime alley for a reason because
look at the family i know the He's got a...
Oh, shit!
He's got a what?
Do you dance with the devil in the pale moonlight?
Come on, Jack.
Let's go before we recognize.
Oh, he's dropping on the money.
His family turned into blocks!
Hey, it's okay.
It's been 10 years.
anniversary of Wayne tragedy still no one arrested in
completely unrelated news balconi walks free again again
what chance does Gotham have when the good people do nothing
but he can rebuild them cities living in fear and then he
gave a coin to the guitar
The little rich kid.
Jack Nicholson created Batman.
There's some kind of problem.
Mr. Cottlepot.
Everything seems to be under control here, officer.
Wait, is this Daddy the Vito penguin?
Like, nah.
Haven't you heard of the healing power of laughter?
You okay, kid?
See, Mr. Wayne out.
Which penguin is this?
Yes, the penguins.
These guys need to pay for what they've done.
But you're not talking about justice.
You're talking about revenge.
What chance does Gotham have when the people do nothing?
Alright.
Dodge.
Am I dodging?
Dodging!
That's right, barrels!
Oh yeah, did you guys see, like, the new update for Star
Fox?
And people were, like, talking, saying, like, why is he
so...
Why is he so...
He's so realistic.
You ain't getting anywhere near Mr. Falcone.
That's right.
Can I catch me?
I'm an adult playing a kid's game.
That's right.
Gotham has had enough of people like him.
That's fucking right.
I got the reflexes.
Oh my god, it's like I'm playing Arkham City again.
Arkham Asylum.
That's turkey, right.
Yeah, they basically read this.
They made the new Star Fox design, like, super...
Oh, I'm hitting Jim.
Sorry.
I couldn't stop.
I'm sorry, Gordon.
Modern, you old man.
I came here to show you.
Not everyone in Gotham is afraid of you.
those that know me kid look around you you'll see two
detectives a cop and a judge oh the paid the bride you beg
right here in front of them like a dog no offense mr twinkle
toes now that's power you can't buy that's the power of fear
Mr. Wayne.
Who are you?
Rallolgool.
Dr. Strange?
I have a particular set of skills.
Skills that make me a nightmare for people like Carmine
Falcone.
I can offer you a path.
The path of the League of Shadows.
Sounds like a metal band.
It's a league.
You make yourself more than just a man.
It's Leo Nisen.
Then you become something else entirely.
It's Lego Nisen.
And that is...
A legend, Mr. Wayne.
There is a rare blue flower that only grows on the peaks of
Nanda Parbat.
If you can bring it to me.
I can join your band.
League!
shadows oh
ah i can join this band in league of legends are we making
an esport team mr leo
league of legends
i am seeking a rare blue flower A rare blue flower that only
grows...
Oh my god, Talia!
My first girlfriend!
You have the leak of shadows.
I will find the flower first.
You can barely use that thing.
No, wait!
Oh my god, I'm so dorky.
Just a dorky billionaire.
Not so relatable.
The blue flowers grow towards the top of the mountain.
You'll never make it that far.
I'll show you.
Look at me go.
Join Marvel Rivals, Brucey, and Starker over there.
You know, I don't remember if I talked about this, but
there's a subreddit where they roleplay as if like, um, as
if they're in the alternate universe where DC made a DC
Rivals game instead of Marvel.
It's really funny.
I love that subreddit.
Oh my god, I got extra.
money BC Alice oh yeah DC Alice where I wouldn't prefer the
help of a yeah the nerve super bad it's not role-play it's
real it's like the bear seeing bears quite a deal super chat
thank you thank you Lego Batman I caught myself in Lego low
no Joker no no rules Bruce there's no rules Batman for Lego
Maverick, thank you for Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
They're okay, I'm so sad I missed you at Zpongo.
They trapped me in the endless merch land.
Oh, we had fun in the meeting, Greer.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I guess you weren't able to catch us.
But I hope you had fun at Zpongo, though.
And got washed out of.
Oh, yeah, I laughed because I tapped out a little bit.
Because I had to scroll up for the...
Oh, hey, look, there's our goat.
I had to tab up.
Look at Super Chat.
Wait, but, like, I could go up, though.
Not?
Oh, I can't.
Only Lego goats allowed.
I wish I was more creative for Lego.
What's this?
Oh, I need to find the snowman stuff.
Oh, there it is.
Put it on.
Oh, shit.
Sorry, Tyler.
I'm so sad.
I place it!
Oh, there you go.
I have to, like, stand really further back.
Can you find a hat?
Look, eco rights.
Nice.
I'm all about equality, guys.
Everyone makes it to the top.
Hello, hello there.
Hey, where's the gold yak?
You can pet the yaks.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, hello.
You can pet the yaks.
Oh, can I rebuild it?
Oh, I can.
What did I build?
Oh, a little rocket.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Well, it's my first try, guys.
But do I stand on top of the yaks?
Oh, no, I'd go up.
No, they're disappearing my coins!
Basically, Lego made a new Batman Arkham game, what the
combat has since Rock Saturday Studios didn't do one.
TT Games was like, okay, you guys will make a new Batman
Arkham games?
Oh, that's cool!
I mean, it has some of like the combat feels very Batman
Arkham style.
Oh, I can hang around.
So I'll do a little shimmy real quick.
It's like the Batman Arkham.
Arkham games for kids.
Alright, I just got MASHIT.
That was way too close.
It's like fought for kids TV.
Yeah, I got a sprint.
Wee.
We'll make sure there's no secrets.
What happens if I...
Oh, that makes sense.
I thought it'd be like Mario crap where there's like
something that'll fly me back up top Bruce what's yours oh
yeah that's gonna be hard when I'm fucking working with your
dad what do you mean we're gonna share a kid together that's
right my man oh you know that makes sense i deserve that but
what if i punch the explosives what would happen then oh my
god if oh sorry oops that's all right oops that's all right
thinking if oh Talia I need to get Talia Talia how am I
supposed to get down if you're blocking me Talia Talia
please Talia please okay how the fuck am I supposed to get
in if Talia how she's literally blocking it
Talia, Talia, Talia!
Talia!
Oh my god, there we go.
There we go.
We did it.
There we go, we did it.
Oh, there it is.
A blue flower!
No goat!
Get out of here!
Thanks, buddy!
Oh...
Use this undulate!
Thanks!
Thanks, buddy!
Hopefully, there's another flower at the summit.
Oh, maybe.
Soup's so rare that it actually has two flowers.
Come on, Bruce.
For justice.
That's how rare it is.
For some reason, I just looked down.
Oh, sorry, I keep trying to punch the yak.
I keep wanting to punch it.
Let's beat up.
See if you've actually launched it.
Oh, you want a race?
You got it.
Wait, which...
Wait, which is which?
Is this my race or is this your race?
Wait, she's going the other way.
Wait, cheater.
But what if I want to go this way?
Oh yeah?
What if I want to go this way?
You know what?
I'll pick this way because you wanted to pick this way.
I wonder what Alfred would say if he could me now it'll be
like my man i win that's right i did it there's no way our
grapples will get us across that gas especially not in this
storm is there i knew there was money in there yeah i went
this one just because you wanted to go this way but but then
that means the other way has money too oh wait where's her
way where did her way go
Wait, didn't she have money, though?
Oops.
Wait, how do I get back up?
Oh, I guess I drowned.
Alright.
I just want more money.
Can I buy stuff with this later, or no?
Oh, goodbye.
Where do I?
Oh, it's this way.
Talia, where are we supposed to go, Talia?
Find a blue flower, but where?
Oh, maybe I gotta build.
This looks like a building angle.
I knew it.
I gotta build.
We gotta build together.
Oh yeah, detect.
Alright, get in, Talia.
We're gonna fly.
This is a totally normal way to climb a mountain.
Let's get this over with.
all right build myself a jetpack i'm holding i'm learning
guys i can learn oh we're alive we gotta be we have to
become bad men oh my god it's a double-decker jetpack wait
we're holding hands guys oh my i'm so in oh my god We're
holding hands.
I knew it.
I knew she was Sundare.
We're holding hands.
Anta, thank you for the raid.
Oh, never mind.
Goodbye.
And then she fumbled it.
I didn't realize there was a rhythm part of this game.
This will take both of us.
All right, we got a lift.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh wait, but there's more money over there!
No!
There was money!
Oh my god, it's staring at me!
I didn't realize!
I thought we were just lifting it!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha!
Fate would not be so cruel.
There's a gold $20 in there, Talia!
And now Damien will never exist.
good he was the worst robin bro didn't he like okay has
anyone seen that comic panel where he threw like where he
threw a stick at damian and i'm sorry where we were damian
threw a stick at dick and then he fucking dies like that's
right that's right i said it i think he was the worst robin
show you guys it's and then he's like dick i never was like
what damien kills a dick yeah the injustice comics and then
he's just like what happened oh yeah but in the animation it
was crazy he threw us in the okay in the animation it's
worse wait animation where when that happens and then people
were like what the fuck happened
oh yeah this one this part
in the okay in the comics it makes more sense where he threw
the stick and then he threw the stick and then Nightwing
Falls down and He fell on a rock and the rock broke his neck
But then in the animation He threw the stick at him And then
he just dies Like There was no rock in the animation He just
threw the stick And then he fucking dies I was like what the
fuck Stick to strife There's like What What we say are the
best five, big, um, the big five Batman villains, Doki.
Obviously, Joker's number one.
Killed by stick.
But we both need a flower to access the temple.
There won't be another for me.
Yeah, he got critical hit.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Rare blue flowers.
Oh my god, it's so rare.
Now we can have two flowers.
Yeah, I've read Absolute Batman.
I think, I love the Absolute series.
It's like literally just, who was it?
What's his name?
It's like some guy's fan, one of the villain's fanfiction.
What are you seeking?
Wait, Absolute!
Oh, Dark Side, yeah, it's Dark Side's little...
Though he will not allow it.
Maybe your father has his reasons.
Fanfiction.
But it's a very good fanfiction.
Are you ready to begin?
I can hardly stand.
Tiger prawn!
JJK?
Lindy hop?
Oh my god, that's how Damien was born.
You are skilled, but this is not a dance.
Yeah, Dark Side is literally that girl who made the the BDSM
novel that was originally a fan fiction of Twilight.
Learn to become invisible to your opponent and defeat them
unsealed.
Daze or confuse your enemies by discovering the art of
Shuriken Jutsu.
Only then will you be ready to face the ultimate test.
He's basically, Darkseid's basically the 50 Shades writer of
DC.
Oh, is that Ninjago?
I've always wanted to read Ninjago.
Or like, watch Ninjago.
Everyone talks about how good Ninjago is.
I have, like, no...
I have no knowledge of Ninjago at all.
If anyone should be worried, it's you, Richie.
I meant watch, yeah.
I heard Ninjago is really, really good.
Like, the lore-wise?
Yeah, like, yo, I've never... I didn't grow up with Ninjago.
Money, money.
money.
Okay, does Lego money actually mean anything, or is it just
a collect-a-thon thing?
Oh, I did just speak a collect-a-thon.
Oh, hey.
Strike!
That's right.
Okay, you can buy stuff?
Okay, that's good.
I was gonna say, is it like a I don't know if it was, like,
something to do for collecting or if it's for, like, actual
Like, I can...
If it actually means anything.
Can I unlock upgrades?
Or...
Or is it more just cosmetic stuff for it?
Oh, it's buying characters.
Okay.
I didn't want to just buy characters.
Alright, but speaking of Collectathon, did you guys see that
Twitter thread about some girl who found the Spyro statue?
And then one of the Insomniac directors was like...
Oh my god, like, can you, like, can we, can you, like, send
it, send it over to Insomniac?
We would love to, like, they would love to have it.
And then the girl replied by, it's like, they're not
interested, even though it was, like, it was literally the
Insomniac guy asking her about it.
That's so funny.
Yeah, so some girl found the, uh, found, um, one of the E3
spy statues from 2000s from an, an abandoned building and
then and then one of the Insomniac directors or marketing
staff replied in the Twitter thread and was like oh we would
love to have like the Insomniac, would you mind sending to
the Insomniac office?
They would love to have it like have it back and she
literally replied they're not interested she's like I asked
and they are not and she was like literally I don't know if
she said She asked her, it was literally like, they are not
interested.
And then someone was like, that's literally the insomniac
staff being interested.
Like, there's like, there you had the fight.
Yes.
Ah, I see our honored guests have graced us with their
presence.
First, let us see if you can avoid the most basic attacks.
Oh, okay.
That's working right.
I'll board it up.
I was expecting more of a challenge.
I assure you, Mr. Wayne, that was merely a taste of things
to come.
Defend the character attack back at the enemy.
Okay.
All right.
Get countered get countered That's looking right Get
countered
Okay, quickly attacking enemies will increase your hit
counter making you more effective.
Okay All right, so I just got to do a combo It's looking
right get comboed Oh Oh, so if I whiff it, it doesn't count.
Okay, I just can't whiff one shot.
Na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-nana-nana, Batman.
It's very nice that they go one by one.
I love that.
I love video games.
Video game logic.
There's 20 of us!
We gotta go in one by one!
To make it fair!
Once your focus is reached its limit, I'm glad they are of
integrity here.
They'll focus by attacking and countering enemies build
focus faster by increasing your look they may be bad guys
but they have standards allow think of the super chat thank
you thank you batman dodge one death b and bro got so mad
here i have fan fiction where bruce is for it thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you it's all about honor and
perform powerful attacks okay oh shit oh my god i killed him
because you think he's okay Did I kill him?
Oh my god, I hit him so hard, he literally just died.
Oh my, this definitely feels like Arkham fight combat style.
Like the part where I like just aim assisted to the other
guy.
Need to focus more.
Can you focus more?
No killing rule, it doesn't count in Lego, Batman.
to perform a powerful attack.
There you go.
Oh, sh- Oh my god, I decapitated him!
Well, you both survived.
He's Lego can put himself back together.
Not his parents, apparently.
I guess his parents don't count.
Lesson one, never let your guard down.
I wonder if this is one of the jokers that eat babies.
Oh, that's true.
He's wing he can kill he's not fat man you're not gonna be
needing that not bad for our rich kids
yeah it's absolute joker absolute joker eats babies you know
how to disappear wait i don't know that tree you can build
that tree in lego there's a lego set for that come we have
much to do looks like we've got a pretty interesting lesson
ahead of us yes the ability to remain unseen could prove to
be the difference between victory and defeat all right oh ow
it's okay i can regen all right i'll grab all these coins
grab all the money
I'll be a trillionaire!
It's okay.
They can rebuild this.
Can't believe they would hide all these coins just lying
there.
Yeah, but I could be richer, chat.
Look, they can rebuild this.
They can piece this all back together.
Whoops.
See?
Like me.
I keep thinking that it'll automatically jump for me.
I keep thinking it's like mixtape where it plays for me.
If you're looking for more than conveniences, you've come to
the wrong place.
Well, wait, I can pet him.
Oh, I can't pet him.
I'll grab that.
Yeah, I'm creating jobs, guys.
Making sure people have jobs to rebuild stuff.
That's all right.
I can punch it!
I don't need to build it.
I could punch it out of the way.
How do I build anything here?
What if I just punch it?
Okay, I guess I have to get rid of all of these.
Can I build something now?
Nothing.
Oh, there we go.
There you go.
I got the parts I need.
The detective.
Maybe you should try aiming at the rubble.
How do I change it?
Oh, there it is.
I'm sorry excuse me princess I'm fucking didn't know I could
change the angle of it there I knew we could do it what see
I knew it there you are I keep thinking I can auto jump
because there's some games there's some games where you you
know how like there's some games where you I'm so spoiled by
those types of games where if you lean towards a general
direction just jumps for you i can't think of it i know i
like i played a game like that before but i always i feel
like a lot of games like hold your hand with that these days
i keep thinking if i just move towards it it'll just jump
for me yeah yeah god of war you see a race and enemies
awareness level now quickly move all right good He didn't
see you.
That's right, he'll never see me.
Okay, but what if I kill him?
Oh, shit!
There we go.
That's right.
I told you he'll never see me.
Not bad for a first try.
That's right, no survivors.
So stealthy.
Exactly.
If they're dead.
If they're dead, nobody can report me.
God damn, I keep...
I keep thinking the game will jump for me.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
I'm sure ready for a more advanced challenge.
Yeah, let's go.
I'm Natalia.
I'm my future girlfriend.
and mother of my child take him out quietly by sneaking up
behind him
splendid as you can tell this method of attack can be rather
rewarding now try to get to the other end of the room
without being easy
so lucky i'm so lucky they all just didn't hear everybody
else dying whoops all right there's anything there's no way
to hear these fireworks all right get over here all right
sayonara bruce wing kills
all right oh i thought that was like oh nice every little
candle oh that's cool even the candles are legos all right
give me a sec talia i'm just grabbing extra money i gotta be
the world's first trillionaire.
Oh, fuck!
It's okay.
Just a little firework.
Doesn't hurt anybody.
Alright, nice.
Oh, open that.
Talia!
Oh my god, Talia, please.
He's like, are you sure?
Talia, why did you leave all these unbroken, Talia?
You're just sitting there begging to be hit.
I'm heading over now.
I guess it's this way.
Which way?
Your powers of observation is down here.
I guess this way.
Oh!
This is literally Batman!
Oh my god.
Came from downtown.
But there's actually...
money over here.
Natalia's not a gamer.
Before facing your final challenges, a minor warning.
If you're spotted by an enemy, you must now face the
consequences.
So, basically, don't get caught.
This'll be fine.
You catch on fast.
Alright, he's gonna turn around.
Okay.
And then, when he turns around, He won't see me.
Turn around.
Okay, and then I'll go back up.
And then I'll go back up.
This is my spot, Talia!
Talia!
I caught dibs!
I was here first, Talia!
Oh my god, Talia.
I've already got three.
What are you doing, Talia?
right get smacked with a fish you're sleeping with the
fishes now talia do something i got three i got my ones and
twos and threes oh my how the did that guy not see her
how many more ones and twos do you need talia Oh,
okay, now you got them.
All right, now you did it.
From the top, bro.
All right, nice.
Talia finally helped.
She finally honed in.
See, she did it.
All her.
Just because she's a woman and she's hot.
Yes, doesn't mean it's all her.
That doesn't mean she did it all.
She just wanted the last kill.
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's like...
But he's not real.
He doesn't have eyes.
Alright.
Oh.
There's a blue here.
Oh, there you go.
Alright, well...
Grab as much money as possible.
It's gonna be important later.
I gotta fund my future kids' college fund.
Alright, open sesame.
Interesting choice of decor.
Get rid of all the candles.
Oh, that's cool.
Wait, the other guy has a- he's holding chicken.
A chicken.
All right.
Hey, there's Roz.
Oh, there he is.
Let's sneak up on him.
Show him how good our skills are.
Look at this.
Watch this.
Oh.
Never mind.
Cutscene buff.
Villains always got the cutscene buff.
Wait, that's not Roz, I believe.
Your skills are strong, but you are not ninjas yet.
Not ninjas?
I worked so hard!
Ninjetsu is the art of patience and agility.
But sometimes you need to strike from a distance.
Today you will learn the use of shiriken.
Shiriken?
As weapons?
Or distractions?
Theatricality and deception?
It's my batarans!
Lesson 2.
surroundings oh this
next lesson should be easy i already know a great way to
distract any bad guys you run into it's not just pointing
behind them and saying look over there is it uh no of course
not it's look over here there's a key difference between
here and there.
Oh my god, Bruce Wayne's gonna be in the next Hokage.
Uh, did you see it?
Look, if it works, it works, guys.
Why would I change my strat?
Alright, here we go.
Knock, knock.
Future father-in-law.
Ah, welcome.
Please take a shurikun.
We'll begin our training.
Oh.
Oh, shiny.
It's like, take your next shuriken.
Ooh, shiny.
Okay, now I'll take it.
How do I use it?
Destroy the three targets by throwing shurikens at them.
I'm throwing weapons.
How do I throw?
Oh, R2.
Okay.
Got it.
wait those are real fire let's see what the fuck is that
that's not lego what the fuck why don't i like the sound of
that oh my god nine out of ten not lego
i can't believe it they're so lazy how dare they use not not
use lego for the there's there's lego rocks my immersion is
ruined they said everything is Lego but clearly that was
alive what the fuck is that that's not Lego too much fire
too many rocks too unplayable I know, right?
Not even a real Lego game.
This one looks a little more complicated.
So complicated.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
Wait, actually.
Oh, my.
What?
Okay, that was bullshit.
That was bullshit right there.
Wait, Talia, I need you.
Talia, please get out of here.
Alright.
Now I'm angry.
I'm going to take my anger out on Lego.
I presume those giant axes are going to stay exactly where
they are.
Surely, right?
Nice.
Um, I'm on the hardest difficulty.
Um, that only real gamers can see.
Obviously.
Oh, fuck.
Never mind.
I did it.
There we go.
I thought it would be faster than spikes.
I don't know why.
I thought it would be so fucking fast.
And they'll never see this come in.
Whoops, what a gamer.
What is that?
They're a sugar in the floor to make noises.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's cool.
Always a distraction.
They'll never know.
All in all, 100% successful takedown.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
That's not true, Talia.
Stop making numbers up.
Just because you're a woman.
Doesn't mean I won't throw the shuriken at you equal rights.
I don't discriminate.
There you go.
Dad.
I'm pleased to see you made it eco rights best rated e for
everyone complete your training with this so progressive Oh
my god, it's my favorite attack in Batman Arkham That's
actually my favorite attack Shark chickens Hey, you can
never have too many friends I beg to differ That's why
you're like get killed need yeah shark it shark it shark it
shark it shark it shark it need to focus more
oh my god I have so much combo look at that combo look at
that combo my aim assist
that's right combo for days
Talia don't distract me don't combo interrupt me right oh
fuck wait if I hit Talia it continues oh I was about to hit
her again you have come far it might continue the combo I'm
just about to slap Talia one more time equal
rights equal fights exactly
Enough.
Rest well.
Tomorrow you will face an even greater threat.
I'll catch up.
Nice.
Who's there?
What's that?
Is that Ninjago?
Is that the prequel to Ninjago?
Yay!
Completed the mission!
Alright, plus one skill break.
oh oh i do get upgrades oh but they're like skill break
upgrades skills follow under two characters combat and
exploration once unlocked the effects are permanent
purchasing the skill unlock critical hits critical hits do
extra damage and during more focus attack just at the point
another hit lands to perform a critical hit oh i can only
upgrade that okay my upgrades will be unlocked as you
progress through the story.
Check back in the game menu when you have more skill bricks.
Okay.
Oh, I can't even read the skill tree.
Okay, it's like, that's not important.
Bruce, that's not important.
You gotta keep on going.
You must learn the tools to bring about great.
Yeah, it's just like the Ark of Games.
Terrible things, Raz.
If you are to join the league, you must not fear the will to
act.
the kids to read, don't you?
You gotta keep going.
They're gonna go back on TikTok.
Hinch person.
Wait, really?
Can't even call them goons no more.
Continuous attacks from your foe is vital.
You must learn to evade multiple attacks from your opponent.
Shurkin, shurkin, shurkin!
I pick things up quickly.
That's fucking it.
Get out of here!
It's shuriken time!
That's right.
Get out of here.
Boom!
Now you see how it's done, don't you?
This guy's not your average teacher.
Easy.
And now for a test of your new skills.
Please try not to disappoint me.
At least it's not a written exam.
That's right.
Where are you spinning?
Oh, shit.
He's spinning to me.
Okay.
That's fine.
If I do shuriken, does it continue my combo?
Oh my god, it does.
What the fuck?
I can't even dodge that.
Wait, that's illegal.
You fucking threw me away.
Okay, that's fine.
Easy.
We always come back to shurikens.
Our parents' death was not your fault.
It's not?
Oh my god, isn't that great?
He's also a therapist.
Oh my god, his daughter.
See, I told you he doesn't care either.
My father?
Yield.
me you've sacrificed sure footing for a winning stroke oh
rub your chest your arms will take care of themselves go
home bruce your anger gives you great power but if you let
it it will destroy you he will destroy you and all that will
be left is mindless vengeance what if i were to ask you to
come with My path is set.
I have to follow it to the end.
Maybe I could show you something that would change your
mind.
Oh?
Something Razz doesn't want us to see.
I feel like they don't utilize Tali a lot in, like, movies
and shows.
It's usually always Catwoman.
I guess because, like, I guess it's hotter.
I guess...
Oh!
I feel like they always...
It's always cat woman, not Talia.
You're just like, yeah, but...
Much hotter when you're... when it's a cat.
Cat girl.
Cat woman is just more popular.
That's true.
I think if you're a comic book person, you'll know Talia
more.
Oh, hey, let's really enjoy ourselves, Talia.
on life wait
a sec look at the vents on the floor i'm looking if you're
suggesting we crawl through those 50 things i know great
idea right that's not what i was going to say see when
you're on you're you're you're in the sun you're in the hot
tub all the ideas come to you oh oh what the
It really is Batman Asylum or Batman Arkham.
Is anybody here?
This plant stopping us from getting out here.
Let's keep moving.
Oh my god, I'm venting.
Something in here should help us clear that plant out of the
way.
Now they'll never know the wall is slippery.
Sure kid.
Oh shit.
Whoops.
No, you're just making a miss.
Yeah, it's all the Arkham games.
Oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Does he know?
Shuriken, shuriken, shuriken, shuriken, shuriken, shuriken.
You think he knows?
He's like, who's that guy?
Oh, that's what the...
That's what it was for.
Stealth.
Hey, he didn't see me either, guys.
I didn't see him.
He didn't see me.
It's just the win.
Oh, that's why there was a chandelier there.
I thought it was just decorations.
I could break it with this.
Oh, I guess not.
Yeah, it must have been the win, guys.
Oh, there it is.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
See?
don't know just like must have been the win let's get these
guys out of the way if you insist all right talia your turn
shirkin shirkin shirkin shirkin shirkin shirkin shirkin
shirkin oh shit whatever happened to not getting cut we
didn't get caught talia what are you talking about we're so
save look they don't know see they're so confused guys oh my
god oh
it's okay it's okay they'll kill each other well watch them
kill each other guys he's gonna do it again watch watch this
He has to.
Look, see?
Oh my god, they're friendly fire.
Friendly fire.
It's working.
I think I can just do that and then they'll kill them.
Wait, what?
They're invincible.
Alright, nice.
Alright, now I'll kill them.
Easy.
See, guys, look.
They killed each other.
Just as planned.
If it were.
It works, it works, guys.
Look at that.
As intended.
God.
Can I break this with my own hands?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Need to focus more.
Let's just get rid of these first.
I need that money.
Oh, oh, it's purple.
Whoa, my controller made noises for that.
The controller was like, that's an extra special money.
It's Urpa.
But how do I get up there, though?
So much money just lying down here.
Oh?
Oh, whoa!
It made funny noises when it's blue.
Oh, that's cool.
I like that.
It's, like, super interactive.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
No camera!
My controller has like interactive noises.
When I grab like the colored pieces.
My little jingle jangle.
Yes, we better find another way.
There's the other guy.
He doesn't know.
Let me just run behind them real quick.
He'll never find out.
Yeah, they're all over there.
Okay, but there might be some cool stuff down here, though.
Any extra loot?
Yeah.
Yeah, it's like the Wii mode.
If I pick up the funny color pieces, my controller makes
little sound effects for it to be like, good job.
It's like my little child jingle jingle.
They gotta give me as much motion as possible so I don't
open TikTok and look at brain rot.
They gotta keep my attention as much as possible.
Much jingle jangle.
It makes sense, to be fair.
Whoops.
That got him?
I think I did.
Whoa.
Like, I could just run around this.
them.
Yoink.
Didn't see me.
Still.
Yoink.
That's right.
I'm gonna stuff you in the locker, nerd.
Let me watch this.
Whoa, who's that?
Who's that?
Oh, wait.
You actually... Oh, shit!
Where is he?
First strat.
Maybe I ought to build something here.
I have to build.
Is there anything I'm, like, missing?
I'm missing, like, two important pieces.
But where would they be?
Oh, here.
I guess I have to break that.
There we go.
Now I can build it.
I gotta build.
Oh, it's my...
own leather.
Nice.
Wait, that means there are people above me, because they're
like, what the fuck?
Where am I supposed to go?
Here?
Oh, here.
The hook in front of me.
Who would have thought?
Okay, turn tab.
Can we fix it by the builder?
Yes, we can!
Oh, it's like...
It's a bed!
Alright.
I'm gonna grab another...
That little blue tablet.
How does he know?
You think he knows I'm in here?
No way.
There's no way he knows.
Alright, there you go.
I don't know why we couldn't rebuild my parents.
It's just blocks.
We'll just re-piece them together.
Nah, there's no way I'm making two.
Why are they all just grouped up down here?
that's cheating
they're cheating guys oh no my combo yeah just super glue
them back together then they'll never break apart that is
true I feel like if you're a billionaire you would like
invest in super glue so you'll never die also for like the
baby Lego stuff.
You'd think it's like the robot situation from that robot
movie where they just order the babies from the manufacturer
and they have to build the babies.
They just like that in Lego.
They just order a new minifigure.
And they're like, we should have a kid.
And then they just, they go to where was it?
Was it Sweden?
Or was it?
Wait, who makes Legos again?
Was it?
It's one of the Nordic countries.
They shipped the baby over.
Denmark.
Yeah, I was going to say, is I have Denmark or Sweden?
Sweden is IKEA.
Yeah, build a baby.
They just order a mini-figure.
They're like, we should have a...
We should start a family.
And they just order a baby.
Okay, where is it?
Oh, I have to build.
Alright.
Break that.
And then we'll break that.
And then we can build now.
oh i just found speaking of someone's talking about
transform yeah build a baby speaking of transformers did you
know in invincible they got optimus prime and megatron as uh
the two leaders in invincible that was so cool i have to
hold this yeah they got the og voice actors for in megatron
and optimus prime to be like Invincible.
So like, the guy who voiced Optimus Prime is that old guy
that started the whole surge virus or whatever.
The start of the virus where it killed a lot of the
Viltrumites.
And then the guy who voiced Megatron is the main leader.
The main leader that Optimus Prime assassinated.
Yeah, the voice actor.
Yeah, I thought that was really cool.
Fun fact.
A cool fun fact.
Oh, fuck!
I'm mistaking the Danish for the sweet.
The Scandinavians are coming.
Fudge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't mistake them, guys.
I just got confused which Scandinavian country did it.
That's different.
I was just confused.
Oh, it's a puzzle.
Okay, it's a puzzle.
It's a puzzle for children, so...
Okay.
Am I supposed to be down here?
Okay, but what if we do that together?
Oh?
No?
What if I stand here instead?
Uh...
But where is Talia gonna stand?
Or Talia wants to stand here.
And then what?
Oh, wait, there's something here.
Talia.
Oh, sorry, Talia.
Wait, what's...
Wait, what's... How do I...
Oh!
Okay.
I was like wondering why I can't break it.
There we go.
I'm so smart.
I got a modifier.
Let's go.
I said sorry!
Okay.
How do I...
Oh, I can unlock these.
Increase the maximum of stud combo multiplier.
Detect enemies for much...
I feel like we don't need...
Like, maybe to collect the stud.
Generate focus.
I feel like we'll need that for sure.
Alright, there we go.
And...
I'll go down here.
This is my vent, Talia.
That's right.
Get kicked!
Talia, where's, get your ones, Talia?
Oh my god, Talia, please.
Not go back in the vent.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
That's my future baby mommy.
There she is.
That's my future girlfriend.
Oh, and I have to do the puzzle myself as well.
All right, Talia.
Alright, my son's future mom.
Right there.
Didn't say that.
Definitely not.
He didn't get the brains from her.
That's for sure.
I might have known they'd locked the doors.
Alright, I go through the vent.
Oh, she can depend on me.
I'm literally Batman.
I'm gonna grab this guy.
Oh, now you help.
Thank you, Talia.
I really appreciate it.
Alright, don't make me angry.
Oh shit.
Alright, we go one by one.
Two.
Talia, get your ones!
Oh my!
You get the...
The plan was simple!
I go left, you go right!
Oh, you only do it when your dad's here.
I don't... I see how it is.
I see how it is, Tahlia.
Tahlia, what about the plan?
She's throwing.
She only does it when her dad's there.
I see how it is.
You only want to do stuff when...
You only want to do the plan when he's watching.
You don't care.
Oh, do you think he knows?
All right, Talia, this is it.
This is where you can get your ones, Talia.
Right here.
All right, down I'll go.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's do it here.
She only wants to try when she can, if she can, in trouble
I'll go after him because he started reading oh no you don't
no you don't now you see me now you don't and I guess I'll
go this way first and I'll just start going here and then
it's just like a little merry-go-round so one by one okay
he's turning around I hope Talia's going by my left right
now I hope she's getting her ones guys I really hope so I
hope she's doing her fucking job guys what I hope when I go
back this way all the enemies will be dead
Oh Hey Talia Wow It's crazy that nobody's dead Well Talia
What you doing over there?
You know I you know what you're right you're right expect a
little too much on you Talia you're you're so right too much
pressure I'm so sorry.
That's it's my fault.
It's This is my fault for expecting the bare minimum.
It really is.
How could I expect that from you?
You're trying your best.
You know what cat woman is better.
I mean, now guys, now understand why it's always cat woman
and not Talia.
Why can't I have a kid with cat woman?
Imagine how cool, how, imagine how much better our kid would
be.
Oh, wait, I do?
I actually, wait, really?
I didn't even realize that.
Oh my god, you serious?
I didn't realize...
Wait, Huntress is Bruce Wayne's and Talia's kid?
I didn't know that.
What am I fucking doing?
I could just turn this later.
I didn't realize Huntress, yeah, is the...
Sorry, sorry, it's Catwoman's and Bruce's kid.
What are these weapons for, Raz?
Gotham's time has come.
Oh, a version of Huntress.
Okay, I was like thinking, like, I'm pretty sure that he's
not...
She's not.
Bruce, please.
For your own sake, there is no turning back now.
You can't believe in this.
I'm saving there are good people there when the forest grows
too wild a purging fire is inevitable and natural as well my
daughter knows your daughter father father father father
please your compassion is a weakness your enemies will not
share that's why it's so important it's what separates us
from them what are you doing what is necessary
The nuke!
Oh, shit!
Perhaps there's time for one last shirking, shirking!
Shirking!
That's right.
I saved my op just for this.
Shirking, shirking, shirking, shirking, shirking, shirking,
shirking, shirking, oh shit!
That's fucking right.
Don't worry.
He'll get stunned eventually.
God escaped the Shurikens!
Wait, what?
That comp?
That still hits me?
Okay, maybe Shurikens is not like the strongest.
Unless...
I just gotta keep believing!
Okay, never mind.
Fist is stronger.
Okay.
Okay, it was Lilf.
If I just started spamming fist, I might have killed him
earlier.
I think she's using shurikies.
Dookie, this is not Marvel's.
You're not Moon Knight.
Lesson two, always mine.
Gran of bullshit!
Ross is your father?
Yes, but there's no time to explain.
We need to leave now.
You could explain while we're running.
They always say there's no time to explain, but there's
always plenty of time to explain.
Alright.
There goes our way out.
Oh, oh, now there's more ninjas.
Whoa, there's a lot of ninjas.
Oh my god, there's so many ninjas.
Talia, come on, they're right there.
Just punch one.
If you punch one, I'll be happy.
Honestly.
I'll be happy with one punch.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Oh my god, there's so many of them.
Oh, shit.
Alright, get out of here.
Oh my god, and they don't stop coming, they don't stop.
They don't stop coming, they don't stop.
Okay, nice.
Good job on friendly fire.
Alright, that should be the last one.
That guy's the last one.
Get over here.
Sorry, I'll get over.
Don't worry, I'll get over to you.
Don't worry, I'm coming over here.
I'm coming over.
Stay there, stay there.
Crack.
Behold.
The element of surprise.
They'll never know.
They'll never figure it out.
Oh, I guess they figured it out.
Why just Gotham City?
If he's just gonna blow a nuke on everybody, just go for the
whole world.
Why just Gotham City?
Oh, ow.
Wait, there might be some stuff here.
Yay!
Money!
Because Gotham sucks.
More
ways than one.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Thank you for warning me just when it was about to hit me.
I really appreciate it, Talia.
Remember, to conquer fear, you must become fear.
That's okay, right.
I didn't expect that, did you?
Wait.
Okay, you can friendly fire.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm built different.
Yeah, I did.
Yeah, I'm right.
I did.
I'm just built different.
Ow.
Oh my god, he broke my combo.
He's just focused on rounds.
How good!
We don't care about the minions!
Okay, we'll use the minions to build up our combo.
It's okay, she'll be fine.
I know, because we have a kid together.
Yeah, she lives that.
Yay!
The yaks revived!
We didn't lose the baddie.
It's like, we'll meet again, baddie.
Oh my god, the rare flowers!
We just put it back together!
We'll find the pieces!
We'll rebuild it!
the secret temple I never liked it can you call him a cab
they've been a nightmare for start they never pay their
bills on time and those ninja masks we make all of those you
know we don't pay on time we've got the rent to pay on the
shack you know what it's like cost of wood is damn he was a
bad tenant I can't I don't believe it.
They were bad renters.
Oh, yay.
Skill break.
I couldn't find the last bonzai.
I don't know where the last one was.
I got the red brick.
He's such a cheapskate.
He has enough to nuke a city, but not enough to pay rent on
time.
So, now you've returned from the grave, Master Bruce.
Yeah.
What's next on the agenda?
I'm going to show the people of Gotham.
Their city doesn't belong to criminals like Valkoni.
Tea?
Very good, sir.
But first, I need to become more than a man.
I need to become...
A furry!
A symbol.
What did you have in mind?
Something elemental.
Something terrifying.
Yeah, I'm sure something will come to me.
Oh, there she is.
Gotham City.
Kite man!
I love Kite man.
Scariest villain in Gotham City.
Oh dear.
Wrong side.
Oh.
Yes, he's more like Gotham.
Kite man, no!
Oh my god, even the children are thieves!
Kite man, hell yeah!
That's the Gotham City, I know.
And love.
No problem.
So many memories.
So sorry, sir.
I don't know where they keep coming from.
I have an idea.
Come on.
Where are we going, Master Bruce?
i'm gonna follow it back here just like old times
yeah gotham always has pvp enabled
here i go that way that'd be something that's where i can
fix this with money you used to love these gardens wait
they're gonna say can i bounce on this oh okay
All right, is this game single-player?
I feel like this game could be a two-player game, I realize,
because of how fucking shit the Talia AI is.
Like, I've been seeing everybody playing this game solo,
though.
So I thought this was a solo game, but I was like, wait,
this is like co-op.
Yeah.
It's like somebody to get them out.
Then I guess we're knocking them down.
Yeah, usually these games are co-op, yeah, I realize.
Oh, if you say so, sir.
Oh, I can drive.
Sorry, sorry, miss input, Alfred.
Those guys were older than me, you know.
This place has seen better days.
Wait, what's the point?
Well, now you're back.
We can get you working on the garden, sir.
What's the point of building a car?
I can't even take it up ramp
Wait what Oh that did break this maybe Oh I can make it
bigger That's why Oh there's my ramp Okay what is it Wait
why did I build the car if I can't use it Just to destroy
the gate I might as well be I should be allowed to take my
car to the next level It's calling to me Alfred, I bet that
old tree would make a pretty nice bridge.
Oh, it's good.
I still brought my shuriken.
I'm sure it would, sir.
Oop.
My inner furry is awakening.
That worked out better than I expected.
That bat.
This is a lot of effort to chase a bat, sir.
The bat is calling for me, Alfred.
You don't understand.
Something is awakening inside me, Alfred.
since we last came this way, sir.
A long, old time, indeed.
The bats leading us to the old well.
He's talking to me, Alfred.
He's speaking to me!
Oh, we got the crane.
Are you sure this is safe, sir?
Hey, compared to what I've been up to lately?
This is nothing.
Alright, let's go down.
Oh.
They call for me.
Are you ready for this, Alfred?
I was repelling out of choppers before you were born, Master
Bruce.
Don't you worry about me.
It's like seeing this bad.
Don't suppose you remember what your father said to you.
I fell down this well?
He said, why do we fall, Bruce?
No, no, no.
He said, don't go.
How did I live?
Excuse me.
Where's the...
Alright, there's no way I lived that.
I was a child.
How did I not?
See, I told you.
He rebuilt me.
Why couldn't I rebuild her?
I felt like 50 feet.
He wasn't Batman yet, guys.
He was still Bruce Wayne.
Oh, the bat started.
That's Duncan.
Oh, oh.
I hope...
Guys, it's just water, right?
Guys, it's just...
It's like eggs, right?
It's just bat eggs.
Come on.
Let's explore.
Yeah.
Those are the bats that specifically lay eggs.
I hope there's a more convenient entrance somewhere.
We have to explore this place.
Those galatians are going to shake you.
Maybe you can clear them out of the way.
Can I break that?
No, I can't really break this.
The Batman is patient zero.
Here we go, this way.
Whoops.
All right, whoops.
All right, this way.
Wait, but how do I...
What?
Oh, okay.
Do I beat it up?
Just about.
I'll find a way to get you across too.
I'll just beat it up.
Whoops.
Push it.
Oh.
Now I'll leave.
It's like I'm done with this shit, Master Bruce.
I don't get paid enough for this.
Is this your idea of a safe crossing, Master Bruce?
Hey, it was the best I could come up with.
All right.
Let's go.
But I like to play my favorite character, Alfred.
And then put up with this naughty-ass brat.
I fucked this.
I would encourage them to move along.
Good idea.
Let's get building.
Build?
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
But there's something over here, though.
I knew it.
Alright.
Alright, let's go building, Master Bruce.
Oh, okay, thanks for helping.
Oh, wow, just like...
Wow, I'm so immersed right now.
Just like the real world.
Just like real life.
Bruce like, I'm helping!
Sure you are, Master Bruce.
You're definitely helping right now.
It looks like we're under the southeast corner.
Wait, what is that?
Wait, is that the Batmobile?
Your father's own car.
Oh.
I took the liberty of making some adjustments.
It's the pre-batmobile.
How do we get that down here?
It's perfect.
for what exactly my base of operations and the symbol i need
to become a cave man oh alfred i'm gonna become a furry
first off we're gonna need a lot of black paint it's going
through the rabbit hole
we are ready oh my god he's making his first suit right now
He's suiting up.
That was fast.
Yeah, that was pretty fast.
Oh.
Guys, I have a feeling those weren't water.
That wasn't water or bat eggs.
Oh.
For some reason.
I have a feeling.
Poor Alfred.
why Batman doesn't hire more staff.
He definitely does not get paid enough to like clean up a
fucking mansion and a cave.
Hold it right there.
Whoa, Jimbo.
Let's dig it down a notch.
He sends his regards.
Alright, continue.
Whoa, now hold on.
I don't suppose you wanna taste You don't take your taste
off.
He has paid in donuts?
Bro, this is a...
Even if he's a crooked cop, this is a bad crooked cop.
We have a duty to the citizens of Gotham.
Boys, remind Jimbo who really runs this town.
I'm gonna take a walk.
Wes?
Now, now, now, back up!
Oh no.
I'm Batman.
He doesn't...
Oh, he doesn't know yet.
He doesn't know he's Batman yet.
Say the lie, Batman!
Say...
Who?
Oh!
What's that?
Bigaboo.
Watch this.
Oh, never mind.
I couldn't go behind him.
No time to explain.
Watch your back.
He's going to know your real voice.
You're using your real voice.
You're supposed to be like, he's going to take you.
You got to use your Batman voice so they won't know.
They won't know that you're Batman.
I am the knight.
I am vengeance.
I am Batman!
All right, that's cool.
My infinite combos.
When will it end?
All right, we'll get this guy out of the way.
That's why they keep on coming, they keep on coming, they
don't stop!
And they don't stop!
Wait, is it stopping?
Ah,
he set the line!
Say the line, Batman!
Man, by rights, I should be calling this in.
We already have veterans?
You're a good cop swimming against the tide.
What would it take to get Falcone?
There's a new DA.
Harvey did.
He's brave enough to prosecute, but...
You'll need hard evidence Hope you've learned your lesson
Jim bow
Oh my god, he's so pathetic What the fuck fell down?
Let's get him What traps
Wait, give me a sec before we get him
give me a sec don't worry don't worry he it won't he won't
get far he kept it's really hard to run when you're full of
donuts jim don't worry oh wait who's that oh nice yeah
collect some loot real quick don't worry it's very hard to
run on a full stomach all right now we got him oh that was
nice of him he waited for us better find a way across look
at that guy look he waited for us he's like oh my god lost
him he thought he lost us that i heard you like when you're
a cop you have to get like retraining tests right he's
definitely skipped out on those tests
what's that why is there a radio over here.
Is there a secret here?
Secret?
No secrets?
Oh, no secret.
Don't tell me he got away.
I don't think so.
Oh my god.
He just, he zoomed in.
Oh, now he locks in.
Yeah, damn, he's fast now.
We started locking in.
Oh?
Or does it?
Oh wait, maybe it does.
Wait, why would I need him for it?
Stand back.
I got just the thing.
Oh, I have foam!
Oh, it's still batteries!
I use foam!
I have a phone gun.
Oh, it's not only do I am not allowed to budget cuts guys
there has been a lot of budget cuts at the precinct dogs are
crawling with bad guys at the better find a safe way past
for the Gotham PD
okay that's good they really need to try harder do they know
do they know oh oh oh I don't think they know, guys.
I don't think they know.
It is time.
Wait, what?
Hello?
Whoops.
I guess I'll fight.
Yeah, Jim can handle it, guys.
He'll be fine.
He's so healthy.
Wait, I wonder.
Oh, my God.
Oh, boom.
Oh my god, wait, that's so strong.
Wait, that's stronger than Batarans.
Oh my god, Jim.
Those arms.
He's been going to the fucking gym, Jim.
Yeah, the pile driver.
Oops.
Holy shit.
Jim goes hard.
Why the fuck am I playing?
Why the fuck am I playing Batman?
Jim deserves his own video game.
Yeah, Batman, who?
Oh, I guess, like, people would have been there if I
stealthed it correctly.
I was like, why did that work?
What's that supposed to do?
This is stealthing correctly.
It's still technically stealth.
Gordon, give me a hat.
I have to push it.
It's like that new big band spin-off show that they're doing
right now.
That's gonna be on HBO.
Do you guys hear about it?
They're making a new big band spin-off about that guy from
the comic book store.
But it's like, he's like hopped.
It's like rated like M or some shit.
That's like Why?
Yeah, and it's like, it's gonna be on HBO.
Apparently it's gonna be like super, it's gonna be like
hardcore or some shit.
Yeah, it'll be like the guy, well this is named Stewart or
some shit.
The fact that it's on HBO is wise.
It's a fucking big bad theory show.
Yeah, Stewart destroys the world.
fails to save the universe.
Yeah, it's gonna have like...
It's apparently some dark, gritty, Big Bang Theory show.
Avoid the weapon will shine before it happens.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's not a gun.
Gotta put a stat to those guys, Prato.
Alright.
Wait, there's a shiny thing right here.
Oh wait, they dropped down.
Oh my god, wait, they did.
That's just other minions.
Alright, let's get these guys out of here.
The other goons.
Oh my god, wait, that's crazy.
Oh wait, there were surfboards?
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Surfboard was the next connectable?
Oh, the donuts are supposed to be drugs?
I love that.
That's why they're like everywhere.
That's funny.
That's like their alternative for drugs.
They're like, man, I can't wait to get my next donut, guys.
Oh my god.
Please, just one more fix.
That's funny.
Please, I just need another donut.
Please.
Just one more donut.
yeah y'all got some crispy cream come on I'm good for the
next one I swear just
one more oh my god and there's like donuts everywhere got
any jelly filled we got something new coming in it's jelly
it's filled with jelly this time and you're like we know how
much you've been loving these donuts I can't just yet so we
got something with extra glaze do you have any of the
declares I heard I heard you shipment of the one that the of
the one filled with strawberry yeah there is a there's a
donut problem in Gotham City guys we
have a donut problem I'm lost where the fuck did I go I
thought they outlawed sprinkles years ago that's At least
makes it more special.
Boom.
Look, me, there's...
Me and...
There's serious business with me and donuts.
Why do I activate this?
Have there something here?
Wait, is this Gordon-related?
No.
I guess we go this way.
Okay.
Oh, this way?
You're the goddamn iron chef, Mr. White.
It's just some simple bakery, Jesse.
But thank you.
That's good.
Oh, wait.
Okay What
are you gonna do with those?
Okay, now we can build.
We have to bake, Jesse.
Uh, let's see.
Oh, what's that for?
I don't even know.
Good question.
Oh, there you go.
There's the pull.
Oh, and then.
What the fuck?
And then what?
Huh?
Alright, give me a sec.
Let me think.
Let me cook.
Oh, wait.
There's stuff here.
beep oh that's what I'm missing never mind this is extra
loot yeah but I got it though I got the extra loot though
oh turn red colors I can't forgetting this is a two-player
game technically that felt a little drastic don't you you're
under arrest last for over concept for illegal donuts yeah
you're probably not gonna like it
carrying illegal donuts blast
what a mess
There was a two-payer alive.
Let's talk.
What does Falcone want with this shipment?
A picnic?
I don't know.
Now get me down from here.
Clever possession of big goods and we're five grabs of
sprinkles.
No, no way.
He don't rub shoulders with schmoles like me.
Who's your contact?
Who is it?
Who's been providing you all these donuts?
But he tries a real nice purple sports car.
I swear, I swear.
Thanks.
Let's get you cleaned up.
Where are they?
They're the gateway pastry.
They're the donuts.
The gateway pastry.
Maybe just a taste.
Just another taste.
Charlie, just one more taste.
Then I'll go clean.
I swear.
Where is she?
Yay!
We did it!
Okay, I need to start.
Oh, wait, I unlocked it.
Yeah.
I got not a red brick.
We gotta start doing upgrades.
I keep forgetting about the upgrade.
Putting out an APB on any purple sports cars in the
Tri-Corner area.
You need a ride?
Bet.
Man.
Oh, great.
Figures he just disappeared on me.
Oh.
Oh, so stealthy.
Oh, now what?
I'm Batman.
Need a ride.
You'll need this.
Oh, nice.
I got the...
The bat...
Batagrap of...
I gotta get me one of these, too.
And here I was thinking you were all shadows and stuff.
Well, I did paint it black.
That's right.
Can't see it when it's black.
This is dispatch.
The citizen needs our help at the truck.
Come on, Metro.
But there are no nearby units.
Over.
I want to upgrade.
Oh my god, the map reminds me of Arkham, too.
Okay, let's see.
Uh...
I feel like maybe...
Maybe this.
For sure.
And then...
Self-take down.
I feel like the focus is always good.
Like not...
I got money.
It's hard to look at the map screen, discover events.
Is there anything important in here?
Oh, wait, what?
What's this?
What did I destroy?
Anything else important?
Wait, there's a money trail here.
That must be important.
Can I exit?
Wait, what's that?
Wait, where is that?
That looks like an important door though.
I think like I heard that this game is also sort of a little
bit it's like open world too, right?
So you can actually like explore this explore the Gotham
City later
Yeah, that's cool.
That's open world There's like Arkham City Wow
Damn right I do Don't worry I have Lego insurance Oh wait
what happens to my car Oh My car is gonna come back right
Guys Oh wait Call for the Batmobile here Okay wait wait
Don't worry I have it The Batmobile will have to wait Wait
Wait, what do you...
Wait, no.
Oh, oh, there you go.
I got it back.
I got it back, guys.
It's here.
Okay, I have the Batman, Batmode, Beast.
Wait, okay, wait.
Let's get the...
Can I change my suit?
Wait, which Batman can I be?
The Batman.
And then we have Party Music, Arkham Trilogy.
Which one is this?
The Dark Knight Returns.
Wait, I want to be...
I want to be Arkham Trilogy right now.
Guys, the car's gonna come back, right?
Where's my car?
Because...
Dude, where's my car?
Bro, where's my car?
Oh, there is.
There's my car.
Okay, nice.
Look at that.
Don't worry, everybody.
The streets are safe when Batman's here.
The Batman ever got his license, by the way.
I'm actually curious.
We don't have a problem here, do we?
This is dispatch.
Incoming Prime Alert and Tri-Corner.
Oh, shit.
There's a crowd.
okay wait what did he say i didn't finish hearing i forgot
that the dispatch is only located in my car you're gonna say
he got back from the monks and then he like went to drink
and then and then he just straight up was like alfred make
get me a batmobile
don't worry fat man's here i'm fat man
That's right.
Who am I?
I'm Batman.
Sucking, right?
I'm vengeance.
Crime stop.
I'm not used to being rescued.
I did it, guys.
Four units.
Looks like trouble is starting near the movie theater.
Anyone able to deal with it?
I did it.
Let's go.
Look guys, it's...
It's fast travel.
Guys, it's a speedrun strat.
No!
Crime is...
It's a speedrun strat, guys!
Remind me to write you a ticket.
What's that word where you'd use it to like get closer?
Like, get closer to another objective?
That's the strat!
Appears to be a break-in of some kind?
Oh my god, you need all of that to break in?
Boom!
That's right, get ready.
Look out, Gordon.
See, it's a speedrun strat!
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
We can rebuild him.
Oh, all right.
Goodbye, Gordon.
You got this
It's better and better and better and better and crime is
saved.
I did it again Oh, that's cool.
My controller also is like an intercom Nice, we got more
times
We don't have a choice.
Where are we going?
Alright, I gotta get my car out.
Get out of here, I gotta stop crime!
I'm important!
Don't worry, everyone!
I'm a hero.
I'm fat mad.
It's like for the ambulances where you gotta, like, move
away, guys.
See?
They're fine.
I'm Batman I'm
Batman sir I'm not physically or mentally equipped to deal
with whatever your situation is please leave whilst I wait
for detective Gordon wait what only detective he's literally
right next to me yesterday I got a call about a purple
sports car driving dangerously around tri-corner not me my
car's not purple guys see they're drawn up with the driver
The thing is, I showed it to my chief, and he tore up the
only copy.
My guess is the perps want to talk about me, guys.
The other guy was purple.
If you can find the poster pieces, you could rebuild it and
identify the driver.
I always got fine pieces from GCPD.
Thanks, Montoya.
We'll be right back.
No, we got fine and missing cat, though.
Oh, my God.
Is Batman truck always dope?
keep driving he just got his license today guys he literally
came back from the monks someone could use this he came back
from the monks what and then like got a car use this i mean
i can't use this
but there's something here maybe the evidence isn't here oh
my god it's just money what the am i gonna do with odds oh
wait hey A piece of the poster.
I found it.
Found one of the posters, though.
Where could the other pieces be?
Oh, it's over here.
I see it.
Okay, that's convenient.
My rail gun, my rail is like so far.
Okay.
Another poster.
If we find one more, we should be able to identify the
suspect.
Okay, he's invincible.
Alright, the last one is all the way over here.
At this moment now, it's my birthday.
Mind if I get a happy birthday song from my...
Of course, Kongo, of course.
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Kongo.
Congo.
Happy birthday to you.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
I wish the last poster.
I saw it like...
Oh, it's up here.
It's up on the...
Wait, where?
It's like up top on this.
Why the fuck would the...
Would it be up... Oh, nope.
Goodbye.
Why would the cop put it...
Rip the piece of poster up here?
They'll never find it now.
Oh, is it not up here?
Or maybe it's up here.
Wait, what?
That's where it was signaling earlier.
I, like, looked away for one second.
It was, like, poster here.
Yeah.
10, 9, 8?
Am I...
I'm blind, aren't I?
Where the fuck?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
It's right here.
There you go.
It's like all the way over here.
That's gonna sit.
Like, where the fuck did they put it?
All the pieces.
Let's go see Renee.
The Crookster Gotham are screaming at Terra.
I've seen a Batmobile for very different reasons.
When Toki is driving.
Kato, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait.
What's that?
Oh, it's a penguin.
Oswald Yeah, it's Cabal Pot The penguin If you really want
to rile him up And I saw the eyes I know that Danny the
beetle eyes Anywhere I know where that creep will be Oh I
love the textures on my cape Oh my you see the seams ripping
off too Alright Let's change the skin I want to use I want
to use the OG Yep Arkham Trilogy.
I will rebuild it.
I'm feeling...
Feeling cooler now.
Stop in the name of Naa!
Liz on a donut dive and miraculously has the parkour skills
of Ninja.
That's game logic for you.
Morty, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't worry.
Your hero is here to save the day.
Catch a criminal and then the city budget It'll be $5
million.
Alright, we gotta find Cobbap.
All it took was $5 million of damages.
But don't worry, the hero is here.
Where is he?
I tracked down Cobbap, but where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Huh?
take it easy sweetheart you looking for me yeah oh my god
the secret weapon fishes his most iconic weapon don't worry
i got my car
the only way to stop his car is to drive into it so much
experience with that.
Don't worry, I've been practicing.
Guys, that's why we were driving into things, guys.
We were practicing for this moment.
It's fucking right.
Get over here!
You're mine, Cobble Pock.
Boom!
How much more do I have to stop him?
Oh my god, it's like, it's GTA.
It's literally GTA.
Wait, where did he go?
Oh, there he is.
oh my god he went backwards oh little does he know i'm right
but i am not right behind him i i did it mission
accomplished i'm telling you yay she completed it this is
downtown metropolis i know it anyway oh that's not I'm a
trap with this.
Ark of a Ford GTA 6.
He's just like, that's not Superman.
Yeah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, he's so cool.
Oh my god, he's on donuts too.
The gateway, the gateway base.
street they're all on donuts i know that reference license
and registration please
get out of here yes you are oh my god the fire legos see why
couldn't they use that during the njago part okay okay okay
you got me you got me what's falconi up to start squawking
King.
All right.
Enough for me.
Oh, Cody's doing a deal at the Iceberg Lounge.
Okay.
What deal?
I don't know.
No details.
Selling on some shipment from the dark.
It's going down later tonight.
Get out of here.
Your dad's gonna be you.
Oh my God.
donut shipment so literally all right you know which Batman
series I miss the anime one I think that was one of my
favorite I love how creative the designs were I know it was
like one of my favorite Batman animated shows I know I don't
know if that's like a controversial take but I just like the
I love the animation and designs for it's so unique where
you at the anime one the one where like where the Joker
doesn't wear shoes where he's like a where he's like a
monkey yeah I can't wait to we catch this riddle guy that
one you guys know that one yeah I actually really like that
show detective soon.
Some sort of prank.
Did Gordon put you up to this?
I did watch the, I watched the one where like, it was
Yakuza.
Oh, did anyone ever, did anyone watch the Batman one where
they were Yakuza?
I love the design for that.
Where the Flash was part, like, where the Justice League
were all from Yakuza because it was like a what if scenario
where each of the Justice League members was somehow born in
Japan and then became Yakuza members And then there was, oh
my god, the flash scene was so cool.
Yeah.
I saw that one too recently.
I think I watched that movie, like, I think like a couple of
months ago.
That one was, that one was really good.
Yeah, it's an alternate.
It was like, it was like a Rouse Agul thing, like where
Rouse Agul trapped Batman in this alternate, or it was
continuation of this other Ninja Batman show where he was
sent back to the feudal period.
And then when he got when he came back in time To his
current to the present It affected the Justice League
timeline Where all of Justice League were transported into
Japan And then like Japan never existed It's like Japan is
trapped in this like Own dimension or something Like Japan
was trapped in its own dimension And then so there was no
outside world There was no like there was just no Japan But
for the rest of the world world and then um and then all
justice league members were like yakuza members we're
probably the yakuza um there's some sort of prank that okay
it's a really good movie i really enjoyed it's a miss and
listen joki talk about favorite shows and driving the same
day time maybe don't be on the road and she's driving
everyone just wants to talk to gordon but i'm batman got
another greetings card from old mr riddles but this time it
had an address inside this is the place but no one wants to
go in there and i don't blame them either we have no idea
what he's got going on i love like the batman movies i feel
like dc animated movies are so good in general understood
i've always loved like the dc movies like the animated
movies however the batman manga where batman turned a baby
and Joker.
No, I actually have not read that one.
Flood, do you think of the Super Chat?
Thank you.
Alright, now Batman.
I think my favorite non-Batman animated movie was It was me,
Barry.
That one was good.
Oh, hey, Ridley.
I gotta use the bathroom.
I'll wear a bag.
We're the iconic slime where he's like, it was me, Barry.
this mirror
ready to give up yet
there must be something i can use around here is it me or or
does the reflection look wrong
do you really think you can solve this
there's something strange about that mirror
oh i'm back oh yeah let me show you guys the let me send you
guys a link to the yakuza justice league that was a i love
the fighting animation for it was so cool i said i could
find it specifically the flash one see you flash uh yakuza
and there's also one where what if superman was a communist
where he let where superman landed in russia That one was
crazy.
Let's see.
Let me see if I can find...
I want to find the introduction.
This is this one.
Yeah, Superman Red Sun.
Right here.
Those who want to look at it.
Our Superman.
Here.
That one's the Yakuza flag.
Uh, Chab, Sorzman, Huel, uh, Yakumo, Shadow, Anne, Solid,
Bite, Smokey, Nexy, On, Nameless Super Chat, thank you,
thank you, also was it Tim Drake, that's the, the, the guy
who, the, did the character design for Justice League and
Batman, um, I love Tim Drake's art, but, oh my god, boy, he
is such a gooner, he, he, If you guys ever seen his, like,
artwork, like, his, what he draws outside of, like, oh, not
Alvin, what's his name?
Oh, not Tim Drake.
What's his name?
The guy who, his, the character design for, uh, it was a
similar name.
What was his name?
The artist?
Bruce Tim was, it was Tim something, I remember.
Yeah, Bruce Tim.
So Bruce Tim was, like, the iconic artist for, uh, uh a lot
of the batman stuff that you've seen uh like the classic
batman show and uh the justice league uh all both justice
league shows and everything he was a character designer and
like majority iconic art style that you recognize from
batman is from bruce tim and he also created harley quinn
but if you ever seen his artwork outside of his corpus stuff
outside of like stuff that he drew for uh for dc he is what
of the ultimate gooners out there like he he he loves
drawing goon gooning art i would just say that he he loves
drawing goon art like yeah he had all the power in his hands
yeah outside of like his contracted work in his free time
most of the stuff he did.
Respect, bro.
Respect.
My man.
He always said artwork, lude.
I remember there was like some stuff that he like drew
recently too.
Also his like, his favorite ship was Harley Quinn X Batman.
He was, he was tried so hard to push for Batman.
Harley Quinn together
All right riddle me this God yeah, he took Hunt he took so
much advantage over it Yes, nobody names her kids James
anymore Riddle me this Batman Was it Batman oh yeah Batman
and Batgirl.
Okay, there was Batman Batgirl and also Harley Quinn He drew
a lot of Harley Quinn X Harley Quinn X, uh, Batman too.
I saw some of those.
That's not it?
I riddled me this, though.
Yeah, I'm like, oh, where is it?
Oh, it's over here.
It's not, yeah, at least it's not him.
Warren, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do get, thank you for the super chat.
All right.
Good morning from Journey.
I am a Batman.
All right, where's the other one?
I forgot, but oh, there it is.
Alright.
This guy has way too much time on his hands.
Time in the wrong hands can be a dangerous thing.
What's this?
Okay, it's the...
It's the...
Oh, got turned this.
Yeah, I can't lose those cops don't know how to do puzzles
for kids.
Who hires them, Gordon?
That's on you.
Oh, I get this out of here, though.
I want to play the piano.
How do I play the piano?
Hello?
What is this puzzle?
World's greatest detective right here.
guys right here oh
maybe a
piano I don't fucking know I'm trying to fucking figure it
out too don't worry guys world's greatest detective right
here why can I pick this up though oh Oh.
Oh.
I mean, I gotta bring the lamp over.
I know that for sure.
But how do I...
Huh.
I look up.
Is there something I'm missing?
Cooking right now?
I'm cooking?
What the fuck is the boom box?
Where could the boom box be?
I'm angry now!
Like, why did it make me rewind this earlier?
Doki, I think I know the answer.
I think you gotta find the boom box.
I am blind.
I'm so blind right now.
Where could the boom box be?
Oh
my, I swear to God, this is a trap.
I'm so mad.
There it.
I found it.
I found it, guys.
I found the boom box.
Why did it make me do that?
But I have a feeling things are just getting started.
Alright, we're gonna need this.
I
look forward to seeing how you do.
I swear to God, is there a riddle puzzlers, puzzle blocks?
Okay, there is.
There is.
It's like Arkham, it's like the Arkham series where there's
like riddle areas.
Riddle amides areas.
Batman, when you're ready to go bust Valconi, just let me
know.
You know where the Iceberg Lounge is, right?
Of course.
Valconi's fisheries.
It's Gotham's worst kept secret.
Great.
Let's go pay Carmine Falcone a visit.
Alright, don't worry.
I got my car.
Looks like you and a new friend have got to work, Kyle.
This riddle guy is also set up all over the city.
A lot of bad.
I like how it's like Lego GTA.
Oh my, there is a Lego GTA.
What is it called?
The Police Academy.
I've always wanted to play that game because that was
actually just Lego GTA.
It's alright.
Everything...
They know this is important.
I'm on important port in Batman business
That's right they won't know what's coming Yeah, those are
Lego City undercover.
I heard that was actually just GTA with but Legos
I've always wanted to play it because I everyone said it's
like really fun All right, nice Look see why can't Chalia do
that?
Look at that Talia!
Look at what this old man could do!
Can't believe it.
Jim is him.
He's him.
Gordon is definitely best girl.
You'll never be like him.
Talia.
I want to see Falcone.
I don't know what you're talking about, pal.
What's the problem?
Says he wants to see Falcone.
Oh my god, it's a twin henchman!
That's what I tried to tell him.
It's a Harvey's henchman.
The Harvey goons.
Yeah, we got fish, all right?
This ain't no secret nightclub.
It's a fish store.
You guys remember that, that clip?
Uh, where there's like a, there was like a bar for goons.
um the two the singers for that club is like the harvey's
goons yeah the two-faced goons were their twins we could
have got a warrant you know
i love the song from that i don't remember what it's called
is it just for us everything is awesome everything is
awesome everything is awesome Batman.
I'm Batman.
And I'm Batman.
Don't worry, I have my permit and it just says I'm Batman.
I like that.
That was good.
That's right.
I'm Batman.
He said the thing.
Looks like we need to step up our security alert.
Oh my god, wait, is this a gay club?
It's too strong to attack head on.
They're weak.
Oh my god, it's the Arkham move!
Oh my god, it's that move from Arkham!
Bro, it's like young men.
I say young men.
Wait, where are the women?
Oh, there are the women.
I was gonna say.
It's an equality club.
Oh.
can't go in let's climb up on the lighting rig to stay out
of sight
or a secret club this doesn't look so secret i'm sorry to
doubt it was a secret club security camera
oh avoid being seen by a security camera Target the camera,
where?
Oh, there.
Where could the camera be?
There's gonna be more of those.
Okay, how... I already broke the security feed, so...
Oh, nice.
I got RAM.
Oh, wait, that's not RAM.
I got CPU.
There you go.
Why did I even break it?
I just temporarily disable it.
This game is better at recreating the Arkham games than
Gotham Night.
But I don't want to show you guys.
Oh, yeah, the song.
Sorry, I know I keep pausing, but I love Batman.
I love DC.
I wish DC did create DC allies.
Um, Batman twins singing.
Oh, this one.
This is what I was talking about.
The twins.
They're like, they're like the, they're like Harvey's goons.
that song is so good i love i love like it i love like the
fact that the twins are singing it oh my god wait diamonds
masters and apex predators can now only solo queue in apex
legends What a wild update.
They're slowly rolling out an update where you can no longer
group.
You can no longer queue in a group in Apex anymore.
It's a slow road day, so it's hitting players one by one.
What a wild update.
Yeah, so they can't have Pred Stacks anymore.
Premates.
Yeah.
I literally just opened Twitter just to see it.
oh my god i might actually play apex again i think that's
interesting i think that's a very interesting update i know
people are like oh this sucks whatever but i still i think
it's interesting because he's gonna meet some fucking you
can you can meet some people from it i know like people are
like because like you know pre-mades it sucks because you
can't pre-made anymore but i still i think it's an
interesting update just so because you can like um maybe
it'll be more fun if you can do I guess but But I think
it'll be an interesting update just to see how to see what
how it goes
That's good.
That's a good one.
That's a good lie He knows what's up.
No, oh wait, I'm speedrun tech security camera there is
whoops that's a good line that's good pr
maybe we can find a way to fuck coney's office through the
vip i thought he said maybe we could find him oh maybe we
can find a way to fuck him i was like bad man actually
you're closer oh never mind it's gone yeah yeah that's such
an that's an interesting i'm just tempted to play just to
see how the updates like.
That won't be Batman.
Oh, that's a lot of people.
I think I can get like two people in here.
Nope, I can't.
Alright, get out of here.
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Keep the fighting away from here.
Oh, sorry, sorry, ma'am.
Crime never stops.
They started it, ma'am.
I'm just doing my job.
He's back.
I
swear I won't run this time.
I'm right.
He's on our side now.
He's going cold turkey.
He's going clean.
He's got the donut patches!
Alright, what do you want, Flash?
Hey, I don't want any trouble here.
Falconi's office.
Where is it?
What?
Falconi's office?
Oh, that's in the basement.
Bottom of the iceberg, you might say.
But he'll see you two coming from a mile away.
So you might want to take the, uh, scenic route.
a good baby open that door wait that's selena cat woman
whatever you say first i'm not gonna get in these guys way
oh yeah that's my other girlfriend you'll find it mostly hey
i told you everything you wanted leave me alone 59.
but she has red hair which parody is which selena is this
you want Hey, which version of Selena is that?
I don't remember her being a redhead.
To be fair, the Selena, I know the most is the...
Is that...
Might be a way...
Oh, true.
Oh, the movie version.
Oh, is it the 2022 Selena?
The Selena I know is the...
The Arkham Selena.
Because after the Ark...
I don't remember...
I don't even remember what she...
looked like before Arkham, Selina.
It was such an iconic design that everybody just swapped to
Arkham, Selina.
Haley Barry Selina, too.
Oh, it's a wig.
I legitimately don't even remember what she looked like
before Arkham gave her a new design.
Because everyone was like, that's hot.
And then everyone just converted it to the the arc of selena
after that did it where did it come from this must be the
door to falconi's office doubt he's left a spare key laying
around
all right let's go wait was there a spare key perhaps i can
build something here don't worry i'll build it
Anything else to build?
Okay, I had enough to build.
Alright, Gordon, let's build.
If we can build something to knock it down, we might be able
to catch him off guard.
Definitely, for sure.
You'll never expect a giant fist.
Fisting in.
That's right.
Surprise!
This is a pretty weird office.
Oh my god, that's where they make the donuts.
That's where they start cooking.
Guys, it's the illegal baking ring.
Alright.
The illegal baking ring is right here.
Not the bakers.
all right let's turn this jim grab that food while i hold
this in place found the source what am i gonna do with sushi
all this food starting to make me oh that's where i'm gonna
do with sushi can't have just a one course meal let's find
two more i'm gonna find the other sushi the other food Oh
yeah, there's a shark.
Of a crowd.
I assume the other food is in that freezer.
It seems like things are heating up.
Or maybe just cooling less.
Oh.
Alright, I gotta grab the ice cream.
Wait, it's not the ice cream.
Or is it?
Hey, who doesn't like ice cream?
All right, we'll place the ice cream here.
One more, and we're ready to serve.
There's the last one.
Oh, it's in here.
It's in the fridge.
Holy shit, that's some Scooby-Doo-ass sandwich.
What took you so long?
You know how Mr. Falcone gets when he's hungry?
I'm working up an appetite here.
He's cooking.
We're gonna cook, Jesse.
Keep your head in the game, Jim.
Oh, you're right.
You're right.
No.
What a great panel.
I learned so much.
Definitely going to use it.
In real life.
Right after Batman.
It's over there.
over here though oh
i'm still going through the vents batman give me a sec
what am i supposed to do here
oh plug in plug in where oh there oh oh batman stuck batman
is stuck oh there batman's got it all right don't worry we
got it
yay unlimited money oh all right got my memory do I go this
way yep surely all right this is it this is the one time
turn around turn around
Turn around.
Alright.
This way.
Let's hurry.
Yay!
Don't worry.
We can rebuild him.
I can just run faster than all of them.
Don't worry.
He's going to turn around.
Oh, wait.
There's a camera.
Don't worry.
He's not going to see that.
not going to see that.
Did he see it, guys?
Do you think he saw the camera?
He's
so stealthy.
Don't worry, you didn't see the camera, guys.
We're fine.
There's no way he's actually looking at the camera at that
right moment.
Get rid of it.
You don't fuck this guy.
That's right.
Get your, get that shield out of here.
all right nice wait who's oh he's still alive he was still
alive the best kind of stealth is no stealth they'll never
expect it you always think you're gonna stealth so you go in
with no stealth they won't know what to do so i wasn't
planning for that
But...
Oh.
Alright, nice.
And then...
Get rid of that.
But never expected.
Alright, let's build.
If anything, we'll knock down that door.
It's something like this.
Oh, look.
Buzz.
Okay, we're gonna have to put this in the Catapult.
And pull.
Yay!
Oh yeah, it's that.
Weeeee!
This isn't what I was expecting.
Even henchman needs to have a break.
We might not have health insurance, but boy, does this make
up for you?
for it so true who needs health insurance when we have bars
that's so true guys i agree look at that they get to have a
little fat pig oh my god he's like i get to
Who's there?
Oh shit!
Stealth!
It's fine.
Like this is our ball pit time!
To be fair, it's good that they're in the ball pit less.
The amount of like...
The amount of like bacteria alone in a ball pit is like...
Not great.
Usually people don't even clean the ball pit.
You think these people are actually...
You think Falcone is actually gonna invest in cleaning the
ball pit?
That's true.
But why is that...
Why is that highlighted?
I guess we're like...
We're more stealth takedowns?
Yeah.
It's not like very hygienic.
Like ball...
It builds immunity, Doki.
It makes...
It builds...
Makes you stronger.
Alright, nice.
Where's the last guy?
Alright.
I'll use a quick down.
Take down you.
That ball pick cleaning machines now?
You think that minimum wage worker is putting all the balls
in the cleaning machine?
Okay.
You really think so?
A lot of them are going to be doing the bare minimum.
You were raised by...
I was molded by it.
Probably not.
Virtually, like, Madrid...
Like, a lot of these people who are, like, tasked in the...
The ball pit are, like, minimum wage workers.
Like, a teenager.
something like their first job so they could pay for the car
that they're saving up for when they get their driver's
license like teens first job
there were disco balls i could break the entire time oh and
there's kids that peed in the ball pit
honey i definitely as a kid i put a ball pit in my I'm
surprised I'm not patient zero for anything I know I'm not
the only kid that's done that guys there is no way I was the
only kid that has put a ball in my mouth
no good ow what the fuck
look as a kid you don't know you don't know these things
You're just like, bump it, yay!
Too long for me.
But Jin should be able to turn these down.
Right.
Oh, this.
Yeah, yippee!
They only make me stronger.
That's true.
I'm only building up my moon system, guys.
We're not the same.
I'm just testing.
this to make sure it's a booby trapped.
Hey, there's a gorilla in there.
He's partying.
Deserve a little break after such a stressful day, huh?
Oh, I missed one.
God damn it.
I don't even know where the other one was.
Can't believe I missed one.
Oh, ow.
Yeah, that would make sense.
Sorry, monkey.
Sorry, gorilla.
good no more partying for you oh goodbye gordon oh my god
he's doing it backwards oh my god he's wild madman what a
madman is that gorilla grud oh hey he came back no that
gorilla was pink oh welcome back oh my god he's stuck he's
stuck in he's stuck in his own little horror show
behind me I want no interruptions I need some quality time
with
all right he's stuck in this only turn a loop yeah stop the
music that's right Batman does not care about your your
music floors down but taking that your hippie shit that's
Fuck it, right?
No, not the music!
Batman doesn't care.
I can build now.
Maybe we can build something to get down to Falcone's office
without using the elevator.
I knew I could build something.
Using this giant drill seems like the next logical approach.
Alright, let's drill down.
He'll never expect this.
Oh shit!
Sorry, guys.
Oh, hey, look.
An arcade.
Oh, happy birthday.
My birthday's ruined.
Let's talk it.
We'll fix it.
Hey, is it really ruined when you get to see Batman?
Where'd they come from?
Should we call Mr. Falcone?
Uh-oh.
Why don't we do the one?
Simple.
Blend in.
We're gonna dance?
That's right.
Oh my god, we're gonna dance.
They'll never expect this.
I can't be a...
I can't be a superhero.
I'm dancing with you guys.
I'm blending in.
I'm relating to the kids.
How do you do, fellow kids?
How do you, fellow goons?
Oh.
Oh my, look at Gordon, go.
Go, Gordon, go, go, go, Gordon, go, go, go, Gordon, go.
You dance a little too well for a cop.
Time for the big finish, Gordon.
A cop couldn't dance this well.
Oh my god, it's the famous Nani's dance.
Oh yeah, now Adam West had the craziest parties.
I talked about it.
I remember talking about it a little bit for Arkham City.
For those who don't know.
He threw the wap at these parties.
He had all the ladies from morning to night.
Hey, Mr. Falcone, where are we putting all this
incriminating evidence and illicit earnings?
In the pile, Frank.
Jack, you were my number one guy.
You leave all this behind.
And for what?
To wear that fishbowl on your head?
The name's Red Hood 1.
Oh!
Joke.
Mr. Falcone.
Why, that's the Joke.
Here's your sample.
Plenty more I'll back for whatever little project you and
your buddies have got going.
Pleasure doing business.
this town deserves a better class of criminal and i'm gonna
give it to him whatever you're planning remember this is my
town i own the muscle what is this some kind of joke do i
look like i'm joking the junkly
The first Red Hood, the whole thing was that Joker had to
wear that the Red Hood thing before he died in the...
Before the toxic waste.
So he's like Red Hood 1.
That's how the Joker was born.
That's why there's a foreshadowing of the fish.
Because that's the Joker's colors.
Time for my associates to escort you out.
Damn right I know my DC shit Sometimes I forget but I still
I've kept up with a lot of DC stuff I've always been a DC
gal I read my wikis She knows sometimes I always get
confused on which universe though There's too many universes
like DC and Marvel has rebooted their shit so many times
that I've like forgot I've like I just forget which is which
sometimes.
I don't know which is on which universe so some of the lore
Like blurs together for me
They like rebooted so many times
I read some of the comics.
I don't read obviously I don't read all of them, but I try
to catch up on like the The cooler lore.
Where am I?
Oh, there I am.
I kept up with lore that I find interesting.
That's why I know a lot about the Absolute series.
And the Batman who laughs.
How many jokes are there in the core and you- Do I fucking
know?
I don't keep track of that.
That has to do with numbers.
You know, you guys know I don't count.
Oh my god, that's so much money.
Wait.
Wait, there's numbers?
I might, I might eat a pizza.
There's at least two.
What the fuck am I supposed to know the code?
Not the, nope, just as I was talking about numbers.
Okay.
Um, the numbers, what do they mean?
What do they mean?
Oh, that's bad.
I don't know how to get this one.
I wasn't paying attention.
Okay, guys, I know it's not 717, because I can't move the
middle.
It's a middle number.
The middle number will always be 9.
So I know you guys are fucking with me.
There's a paper on the chair?
There's a chair?
What do you mean there's a paper on the chair?
First off, there's a chair?
How many stitches on Pat Matt's starter utility belt?
Raz, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Um, at least one.
Oh my god, there it is.
There is a chair.
Oh, nine years.
Oh, my God, I swear to you.
Nine.
Six.
Okay, wait, I remember.
Okay, one is six.
This one is six.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Are you fucking kidding me?
There we go.
Yay.
We got the filthy witch mod.
fire is
he okay
okay wait but there's more loot here i'm so rich now guys
look at how much money i have oh my god
turning here
oh the red hood people
all right Don't worry, I've got you.
Combo for days!
That's fucking right!
Whoa!
Does someone said more combos?
Alright, let's get him out of here.
That's right.
Don't expect this.
Oh my god, we're still comboing!
That's right!
This combo never ends!
Oh my God, now this is a combo.
Get out of here.
All right, let's see.
Any secret?
Oh, no secret.
That's right.
Don't worry, Batman doesn't kill.
We can put them back together.
Oh, there's Selena.
There's Catwoman.
Ow!
Oops.
If we super glue our pieces together, does that make me
invincible?
Oh,
shit.
All right.
Back to jail, you go.
What the fuck did Harvey Dent do?
man these hacks no but the pieces not the legs and arms they
never get my good side where's Gordon where it is Kathy
Rogers has donut sprinkles on their hands okay got loan
shark king shark loaning fish laundering illegal use of a
flounder Falcone what it handed at the scene how in the
world Harvey you wouldn't believe me even if I seriously
just jump back I'm not even sure I believe it oh my god not
the sprinkles.
Yay!
Skill break.
Oh, I got Adam Wuss!
Adam Wuss Batman!
Alright, I was already four hours.
It's been really fun.
Mother, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, the classic fit.
Yo, gee.
The one that didn't hide anything.
Dude, Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I have to go work now and pretend that I...
Oh, my God, that was loud.
Is it done, Master Bruce?
We got him, Alfred.
Your parents would be proud, sir.
I'm a productive part of society.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I need to get back to the cave, but this place is swarming
with cops.
Back in the day, your forefathers had a whole network of
tunnels leading into Gotham from here.
You could use one of them to get back unseen.
Great idea.
Oh, and Alfred, I'll be bringing a friend.
Oh, a friend, sir.
Well, good for you.
I'll make myself scarce.
It definitely doesn't get paid enough for this shit.
You're going to tell me where we're going exactly?
I, uh, Batcave.
We need to learn more about the bears Red Hood 1 got from...
All right, I got it.
I gotta change clothes.
Bronze Age.
Oh, it's the Bronze Age.
Oh, it's not Adam West.
Batman.
It looked like it.
Because he was also blue.
The party music.
Even from the start, Jim Gordon has never been able to...
Oh, yeah, there it is.
The original Jim Gordon.
Alright, let's go.
Don't worry, the roads will be safe.
What's this here?
How do I open it?
Shouldn't be too hard to open.
Alright, but how do I open it?
It's up from up here?
Whoops.
Oh, there it is.
All right, Jim.
We need you to go down.
There you go.
Wow.
It's almost like the security is not that great for Wayne
Tech.
A little concerning, Dad.
Maybe we should invest more on security, Father.
It's a little concerning.
All right, there's one of them.
Okay, we just gotta follow the light.
Why?
How do I get rid of that one?
Okay, the next one's up top.
Oh, there it is.
Tokyo's good 50 years ago now.
Oh!
This is my fast travel.
Okay, I can now fast travel.
travel back home.
It's like my dad's passport was one, two, three, four.
Is this really necessary?
Hold on.
Yeah, it's a big ass map.
Oh, yeah, my friend's gonna drop by.
We must not see how messy this is.
No, my bat underwear!
Hey,
careful with that.
It's an antique.
Just like its owner.
Oi, cheeky.
Uh, keep it.
It suits you.
Maybe you should practice a bit before you take it out and
bubble.
You shot a bat!
My computer's on the upper level, but we need to access that
elevator to reach it.
Alright, clear the path.
Oh, I have two guns now.
Oh, shit, wait, that's OP.
What the fuck?
All I have is my battery and then Gordon has this?
It's so sad.
Okay, there we go.
At least I have this.
I just...
Compared to the fucking ricochet bullets.
Just my little fucking batter ant.
Wee!
Let's hit up and see if we can figure out what's in the
spare.
A little tink.
It's so pathetic.
We had to nerf Batman.
Wait, what the fuck?
Gordon, go down!
Oh shit.
There was like something over there though.
How do I even get that?
I don't see like a hole.
We need to get the power back on to run our analysis.
Good.
I can barely see a thing.
Let me down here.
Oh, it is down here.
Wee!
Wait.
Let me uh...
No!
Alright, I'm gonna call it here.
Fuck this.
It looked like it was like...
Twerky, got the full.
Alright, I gotta call it here.
Guys.
Ah!
We have a lot of weekends.
So I gotta make sure I don't...
Stream, I don't overdo the stream and stream my voice.
That was fun though, for my your first lego game i'm having
a good time guys yeah i got in pole dancing i was like i
gotta stop we got it yeah that that's a good way to call
here that's a good way to end it oh yes the gold gold
adventure gold i'll do it tomorrow because i'm gonna be
right now um but anyway guys because i still need to make my
schedule i will do it tomorrow yes because i wasn't i almost
forgot about the codes but tomorrow for sure i'll be adding
up Gold, gold, adventure, gold codes.
Hey, guys.
I have three game codes for it, too.
Anyway, that was, it's been really fun for my first Lego
game.
I had a great time with hanging out with you guys today,
dragons.
And guys, I'm going to call you here.
I hope you guys had a fun time watching me experience Lego
games for the first time.
I'm going to make my schedule after the stream and grab some
food as well.
Next, thank you, Mr. Pritchard.
Thank you, thank you.
I have great memories of Lego games.
Glad you're having fun.
Yeah, I'm having so much fun.
I love the writing for it because they have to be like no
drugs, so it's donuts.
I love the writing that they do for this game because, you
know, there's a lot of adult themes in this in Batman in
general.
So the way they try to make it more kid friendly is really
funny.
And the writing is really fun.
Like all the references, too.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check.
You have the legal donuts.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time.
everybody bye guys uh bye